Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Facebook hat gedroht, aus Europa abzuhauen.
Wem denn? Wem wollen die denn damit drohen?
Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundsechzig. Heute sozusagen der Rundumblick vom dreiundzwanzigsten September zweitausendundzwanzig. Direkt ins Hörge.
Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn, wir haben extra gewartet solange, dass wir, dass wir diese schöne Datum ähm hatten für unsere Aufzeichnung.
So was ist an dem Datum so schön? Ach so, die dreiundzwanzig, meinst du? Naja gut, machen wir jetzt nur noch monatlich oder was?
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen äh hinter unserem Zeitplan. Es haben sich verschiedene Probleme ergeben. Technischer Natur und äh ja, Termine und Pipapo und Zeug.
Wie das so ist, passiert.
Deswegen, deswegen machen wir jetzt ganz schnell weiter, oder?
Äh ja, gibt nicht viel Zeit zu verlieren.
Genau, wir haben Feedback bekommen. Es, ich finde es immer schön, wenn wir mehr Feedback bekommen und ich merke, das ist, wenn man ähm äh wie so ein YouTuber,
Fragen stellt zu Themen, zu denen alle was sagen können,
und das war insbesondere zum Telefonbuch der Fall, ja? Und da fand ich, möchte ich mal ein bisschen von dem Feedback vorlesen. Also, ich habe mich ja gefragt, warum man
Im Telefonbuch stehen wollen könnte, ja, weil das für mich absolut irrsinnige Idee ist, in einem Telefonbuch zu stehen. Und da hat uns ähm,
Robert geschrieben. Guten Morgen Linus. Zum Thema, warum will man im Telefonbuch stehen? Ich arbeite,
Ich arbeitete von neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig bis neunzehnhunderteinundneunzig bei einem Fernmeldeamt in Bayern in der Telefonauskunft
damals verpflichtet, sich im ins Telefonbuch eintragen zu lassen. Geheimnummern gab es nur für Prominente. Die einzige Möglichkeit, den Eintrag ein wenig zu anonymisieren war, den Vornamen abzukürzen und die Straße wegzulassen.
In der Auskunft wurde damals hauptsächlich die Nummer aus unserer,
Wurden damals hauptsächlich nur mal aus unserer Region erfragt. Jeder von uns kannte die Nummer der Bahnauskunft, der Taxizentrale,
oder eines Pizzadienstes auswendig. Damals wurden die Bücher wirklich gebraucht, aber ich gebe dir Recht, heute sind sie komplett überholt, obwohl ich jahrelang damit gearbeitet habe, nutze ich selbst schon lange,
mehr. Ja, so ändern sich die Zeiten, aber mir hat auch ein äh Freund erzählt, wie er damals, was weiß ich, irgendwie,
weißt du, in einer anderen Stadt war und eine junge Dame kennengelernt hat und dann konnte er irgendwie nur noch,
Vornamen oder also den Nachnamen auf seinem Arm erkennen, hat er die Nummer falsch abgeschrieben und musste dann in diese Stadt fahren, um im Telefonbuch unter dem Namen nachzuschlagen.
Und äh die Telefonnummer zu finden. Also im Prinzip so so ein ausgedrucktes, ne.
Ja, so ein Stalker-Verzeichnis irgendwie so. Mhm.
Aber wie.
Service.
Genau,
Siebka hat uns auch dazu geschrieben, hier sogar Stalking, also Service Service, den Wiebke schrieb uns, es gibt auch heute noch Menschen ohne Internetanschluss, Senioren, meine Mutter zum Beispiel, Menschen, die am Existenzminimum leben,
Technikfobe. Für die ist das Telefonbuch immer noch wichtig, meine Mutter ruft jetzt zum Beispiel immer mich an, wenn sie eine Telefonnummer braucht, damit ich im Netz danach suche.
Du kannst dir, du kannst dir ja die Nummer von Robert geben, der der macht das sicherlich gern.
Aber ich meine, stimmt schon, also das, dass man so diese Nummern, also was ja eigentlich,
das eigentliche Telefonbuch ist, war ja gar nicht das Telefonbuch der Privatverzeichnisse, sondern was auch heute noch eine gewisse Bedeutung hat, ist halt das Branchenfernsprechbuch,
Weißt du, das ist immer so ein bisschen dünner daher kam und voll.
Seiten, meinst du?
Richtig, gelbe Seiten heißt das, dann hieß das dann irgendwann, genau. Das war das Branchenfernsprechbuch.
Das war, das war so die die erste dot com Blase.
Ja nee, ich meine, das hat auch heute noch eine gewisse Relevanz, weil es ja jetzt auch nicht so normal ist für alle Leute, einfach mal so ähm.
Was weiß ich, im Netz zu suchen, weil da kommt ja dann auch eine ganze Menge Scheiße und,
also die gelben Seiten, Entschuldigung, haben äh diesen Vorteil, dass sie halt einfach auch nach Branchen sortiert sind. Wenn du dann Friseur brauchst, dann schlägst du einfach unter Friseur nach, wenn du noch einen Klempner brauchst, klickst du einfach unter Klempner nach, ne.
Dass er allerdings damals irgendwie die Nummer seines Pizzadienstes auswendig kannte,
Ja, der Robert bezweifel ich ein bisschen, mal zu dem Zeitpunkt als Telefonbücher so richtig auf Vogue war, gab's eigentlich gar keine Pizzadienste. Aber die Taxizentrale, das weiß ich auch noch auswendig. Von vor dreißig, vierzig,
gefühlt hundert Jahren. Bahnauskunft wiederum misst sich glatt nachdenken. Zeitansage war immer sehr schön.
Wenn man gar keinen mehr hatte, mit dem man telefonieren konnte.
Du, ich habe ich weiß nicht, hast du in deinem Leben mal bei der Zeitansage angerufen.
Habe ich gemacht, ja. Weil mein, weil mein Vater.
Okay, was wolltest du da von was? Was wolltest du von denen wissen?
Mein Vater hat mir erzählt, dass da eine arme Sau sitzt, die ganze Zeit die Uhrzeit sagen muss und ein anderer, der die ganze Zeit pfeifen muss.
Beim nächsten Tod ist es so und so viel Uhr und dann jemand anders muss immer pfeifen.
Gar nicht, ob ob ich damals schon pfeifen konnte, aber ich weiß, dass mein Vater mir das erzählt hat, ich habe das nicht geglaubt, aber ich war natürlich dann schon irgendwie
als Kind dann bemüht dir irgendwie aus ihrem Zeitakt zu bringen, ne? Dass die mit der Uhrzeit nicht mehr die durcheinander zu bringen, irgendwelche anderen Zahlen zu sagen. Und da wurde mir dann schon klar, Technik ähm.
Ist, was beeindruckend ist, ja.
Das war so eine Schallplatte, ne? Mit mehreren Armen und so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das gemacht haben. Ich weiß.
Ganz tolle Technik. Ja, es ist wurden verschiedene Techniken gemacht. Es gab was mit Magnetband und später, weil sich das natürlich gut abgenutzt hat. Haben sie dann irgendwie auch so ein äh mehrarmige Schallplatte oder Magnetplatte gehabt, die tatsächlich sozusagen,
das in gewisser Hinsicht äh mechanisch ähm automatisiert hat. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass da äh eine Menge äh Hörerinnen und Hörer gibt, die auch dazu umfangreich,
weggeben können, weil sie da irgendwie mal daneben gestanden haben.
Eine Schallplatte wäre echt cool, weil dann könnte da so ein DJ stehen, ne, der so mit der Funkuhr immer so ein bisschen nachstretchen muss und dann ist es auch wirklich genau.
Das fehlt mir eigentlich auch auf Festivals, dass die DJs einfach zwischendurch nicht auf man die Zeit ansagen können.
Beim nächsten Beat ist es zwölf Uhr, dreiundzwanzig Minuten und vierzehn Sekunden.
Alles klar, also unser Wunsch fürs nächste Festival, also sollte es nochmal Festivals geben.
Möchte gerne die Zeitansage haben vom DJ. Ja.
Okay, dann haben wir über Warnapps gesprochen, auch ein.
Thema. Das ist natürlich äh viele Menschen interessierte, wo sie sich angesprochen fühlen. Also, Warn-App hier, den fehlgeschlagenen ähm Alarmtag oder wie der da hieß, ne? Wo diese Katastrophe von Warn-Apps.
Ähm nicht wirklich funktioniert haben. Und ähm da sagte dann Michael, also wir wir haben ja gesagt, okay, es gibt diese Warn-Apps.
Die sind vermittelt. Das ist äh wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt geeignet, um viele Millionen Menschen zu alarmieren.
Besser wäre, Sale Broadcast oder notfalls auch die Sirene. Äh Michael antwortete dazu zu den Warn-Apps. Ihr in Berlin denkt wieder nicht an Leute wie mich, die im Funkloch leben,
Zu Hause werde ich mit den Apps wenigstens über das WLAN gewarnt, beziehungsweise würde gewarnt werden, wenn es funktionieren würde. Aber im Ernst,
Das ist wirklich der einzige Grund, den mir einfallen will, warum er eine App bevorzugt. Ich sehe das aber nicht als Argument gegen Broadcast, warum macht man,
nicht einfach beides.
Alles. Sie reden auch dazu, also es gibt es gibt natürlich einen Grund, warum man,
warum Apps sinnvoll sind? Schlicht, weil Apps mehr mehr äh Kontext bieten können, weil natürlich irgendwie sofort eine Karte aufmachen kannst und
sehr viel mehr äh Textbilder, was weiß ich, sonstige weiterführende Informationen anbieten kannst. Das kriegst du jetzt in so eine Sirene nicht unbedingt rein und äh auch so ein Casting können ja halt auch nur in wenigen Worten darlegen, was so ungefähr gerade das Problem ist.
Ja, ich will ja auch keine Zeitung, also es geht ja hier wirklich nicht darum, dass die uns jeden Tag zuspamen und sagen, klicke hier für weitere Informationen, hast du noch ein Bild und ein GIF, sondern es geht ja wirklich um Katastrophen, ja. Also irgendwie sowas wie.
Ja gut, aber wenn da der der String nicht ausreicht, da steht dann halt nur so Gefahrgefahr, gehen sie nicht aus dem Haus, denn davor steht ein.
Ja, Tim, ich glaube, dass äh ich will jetzt hier keine realistisch erbadbaren Katastrophen im Jahr zwanzig zwanzig beschreien, aber.
Aber du weißt schon, dass wir in drei Wochen so eine Nachricht haben werden, wo drinsteht, weil es dringend zu kurz große Katastrophe ausgebrochen. Das passiert doch immer dann.
Zu dem zu dem Thema äh ähm kommentierte dann noch Bootsrapper,
nur falls es nicht bekannt war.
Das System aus den Niederlanden Griechenlanden äh Griechenlanden, aus den Griechenlanden, den Niederlanden äh und Co nennt sich EU-Elert,
und ist laut Wikipedia ab zwanzig zweiundzwanzig Pflicht für alle EU-Länder. Ich bin gespannt, ob es Deutschland schafft,
Dass vor der Deadline für unter einhundert Millionen Euro zu implementieren. Und da kommentierte dann Beate sehr aufschlussreich dazu mit einem.
Artikel aus dem März, den hat äh Beate damals aufmerksam gelesen und äh sich offenbar äh im im Hinterkopf behalten, der es tatsächlich enorm aufschlussreich, wo es nämlich.
Im Prinzip auch die Corona-Warn-App so allgemein, wie haben denn die Leute so die Menschen informiert, weil Sale Broadcast auch in anderen Ländern zur äh zur zum Einsatz kamen, den Leuten zu sagen, sie sich die Finger waschen,
und,
Dieser Artikel ist äh bei also auf T Online DE erschienen. Und jetzt habe ich den grade hier gar nicht in den Shownotes verlinkt. Der ist,
glaube ich, von jetzt kann ich den Autor nicht sagen. Fällt mir äh in denen. Auf jeden Fall ähm.
Zitat aus dem Artikel, wer beim Bundesamt für Katastrophenschutz nachfragt, bekommt als Antwort zunächst eine Erfolgsmeldung für die Warnapp Nina genannt.
In dieser Woche wurden drei Millionen Euro vom Bundestag bewilligt, die das Amt in Nina stecken kann.
Warnhinweise bekommt, wer die App auf seinem Handy installiert hat, die seit zweitausendfünfzehn angebotene App werde der nächsten Wochen für eine Nutzung von vierzig Millionen Nutzern ausgelegt
Wer findet den Fehler? Ja
Also wenn du wenn du eine Alarm äh eine Warn-App für vierzig Millionen Nutzer hast im Land mit über achtzig Millionen Einwohnenden, hast du natürlich ein Problem. Und da wird auch Malte Spitz.
Vielen hier natürlich bekannt als Politiker von den Grünen
zitiert, der damals schon sagt, aus Gründen der äh Möglichkeiten der, ne, der Skalierung und des Datenschutzes der internationaler Standard.
So und dann wird auch erklärt, warum in Deutschland offenbar diese Broadcast-Sache nicht durchgesetzt wurde
Die Bundesnetzagentur erklärte auf Anfrage, dass es in Deutschland keine rechtliche Grundlage gibt, Telekommunikationsanbieter zur Versendung von Warnungen zu verpflichten,
Das müsse wenn, dann im Telekommunikationsrecht verankert werden,
Nach Informationen von T Online entspricht das aber nicht der Philosophie im Wirtschaftsministerium.
Das ist gut. Ja.
Philosophie, das Wirtschaftsministerium als Philosophische Städte.
Wir würden das ja ganz gerne wir würden das ja gerne gesetzlich ermöglichen, aber da gibt es philosophische Gründe, die dagegen sprechen. Vielleicht sollten sie sich in Philosophieministerium umbenennen.
So und dann, jetzt kommt, ich ich gehe auf den Artikel, den Beate da äh rausgesucht hat, so ausführlich ein, weil jetzt kommt ähm
Der entscheidende Punkt, sie hat nämlich auch kommentiert zu Bootstrapper, der ja sagt, wie wird sich denn Deutschland jetzt darum drücken,
implementieren müssen, ja? Und jetzt wieder Zitat aus dem Artikel, vor allem auf deutschen Druck ist demnach eine Ausnahmeregelung in eine
europäische Richtlinie für ein öffentliches Wahlsystem aufgenommen wurden. Bis zum einundzwanzigsten Juni zwanzig zweiundzwanzig sollen die Mitgliedsstaaten demnach dafür sorgen, dass Anbieter von mobilen Nummern gebundenen interpersonellen Kommunikationsdiensten,
öffentliche Fahndung an die Endnutzer übermitteln. Das zielt vor allem auf. Starten können aber festlegen, dass ihr Alternatives genauso effektiv ist.
Deutschland sieht bisher in seinem Mix an Warnkanälen von App
Durchsagen im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk und Sirenen eine solche Alternative. Also mit anderen Worten, wir haben schon damals dafür gesorgt.
Dass wir ähm diese inzwischen schon in die Jahre gekommene Technologie ähm,
nicht nutzen, obwohl sich sogar die EU dafür ausgesprochen hat, dass das wahrscheinlich sinnvoll sein könnte, so etwas zu haben.
Spannend oder?
Geil finde ich auch die Formulierung, mobiler Nummern gebundener interpersoneller Kommunikationsdienst.
Ja
Nannte man, glaube ich, früher einfach Telefon und äh oder Mobiltelefon, um genauer zu sein, ist ja eine interessante Formulierung. Ja, ach, ich weiß nicht, ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, warum,
Ich meine, die tun ja auch so die ganze Zeit, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie eine besondere Last, die hier auf den Telekommunikationsunternehmen liegen würde,
Mann, wir reden hier von der Übermittlung eines Text-Drinks, über ein klar
definiertes Feature in Mobilfunknetzen, da nimmt man den String, führt den da ein und dann wird der versendet und dann ist fertig der Kuchen
Also es ist das ist wirklich so ein Pipifax, warum er da so einen Tanz äh machen muss und auf einmal philosophische Hürden sieht, dass es mir ehrlich gesagt ein Rätsel.
Man ey.
Also, der Artikel ist übrigens von Lars Winant auf äh T Online DEL erschienen und äh der unter dem Titel Deutschland macht beim Handy Alarm für alle nicht mit.
Ja, also danke Beate für die äh Empfehlung. Ja, im weiteren Verlauf ist dann jetzt auch tatsächlich der Herr Unger,
ähm der dem Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe Vorstand.
Ähm von seinen von seiner Pflichten, äh von seinen Pflichten entlastet worden.
So soll abgelöst werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon erfolgt ist.
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre schon erfolgt. Also er hat auf jeden Fall das volle Vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen und kann sich jetzt,
kann sich jetzt woanders, kann sich jetzt neu orientieren, so und jetzt.
Gilt's natürlich auch, Protest dagegen zu sagen, so, ich meine
Andererseits klar, so ein Test wird gemacht, damit man erkennt, was schiefgeht und dann kann man sich darum kümmern. Andererseits würde ich halt sagen, weißt du, wer einen Test macht, der dermaßen in die Hose geht, äh der hätte sich halt vorher drum kümmern müssen, dass der Test vielleicht äh,
bestanden wird. Also insofern ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, wie man das sehen soll, äh auch wenn hier Deutschland sogar auf EU-Ebene für Ausnahmeregelungen lobbyiert, nur um eine Technologie, wo wirklich einfach,
klar ist, dass sie geeignet ist.
Nicht implementieren zu müssen und wenn es gegen die Philosophie des Wirtschaftsministeriums spricht.
Also Telekommunikationsanbieter, Betreiber eines Land fasst das ganze Land umfassenden Funknetzes nicht dazu zu verpflichten,
Notfalldienste an zum äh anzubieten, ne? Dann fragt man sich, was denn die Philosophie in dieser Bundesregierung ist, wenn man Menschen äh oder Unternehmen erlaubt ähm Infrastrukturen zu bauen.
Ich kann dir sagen, was die Philosophie ist, die Philosophie ist, dass man die ganzen Telekommunikationsunternehmen zu überhaupt nichts zwingt, überhaupt irgendwas anzubieten. Und das funktioniert super.
Ja, zum Beispiel, ne, das ist auch eigentlich klar, warum, warum wir hier keinen, warum wir hier immer noch so viele Funklöcher haben, ne? Das ist gar kein Funkloch, das ist einfach nur eine philosophische Hürde.
Nee, das sind einfach Funklochanbieter.
Vogellochanbieter.
Darum geht's, ja. Das, es gibt immer wieder störende äh Netzabdeckungen zwischendurch. Aber der Kerndienst des Funklochs muss einfach erhalten bleiben.
Grundversorgung.
Grundversorgung als Funklochanbieter.
Also das wird diesen Funklöcher. Ich habe gerade noch von äh Friedhelm Geist einen Artikel geisten Artikel gelesen.
Auf Golem hier in ähm in Grünheide. Bei Berlin wird ja, soll ja dieses Tesla Werk gebaut werden.
Wird auch schon.
Ja, genau, wird gebaut, hat aber noch keinen äh noch keinen äh noch keine Baugenehmigung, ne.
Noch kein Netz, denn die bauen ja trotzdem die bauen ja trotzdem. Das ist ja überhaupt das Geile, dass alles vorläufig.
Ja aber wenn der, wenn der wenn der Mask erfährt, dass es da gar kein Internet gibt, dann im Moment zanken die sich ja noch um das Wasser, ne, aber da sind auch wieder Leute am.
Eigenen Satelliten an, der hat überall Netz.
Da sind auch wieder Leute am Protestieren. Die wohnen im Nichts, ja,
im Epizentrum des Funklochs und der wirtschaftlichen Hoffnungslosigkeit und dann kommt irgendwie Elon Musk und sagt, hier mit einem der.
Aufsehenerregendsten und am schnellsten wachsenden Unternehmen dieses Planeten. Ich schenke euch eine Fabrik und vierzigtausend Arbeitsplätze, ne. Und weißt du, was die sagen? Wo sollen die denn parken?
Die haben ernsthaft, denn da ist jetzt eine Bürgerbewegung, die sich dagegen wehrt. Oh Mann, ey.
Es gibt immer ging alles immer irgendwie irgendein Grund dagegen zu sein.
Ja, aber das ist schon wirklich also wie kannst du.
Ja, okay, aber genau, gibt Leute sind sind dagegen. Das entspricht nicht deren Philosophie.
Können sich ja mit dem Wirtschaftsministerium verbinden. Das ist auch ein philosophisches Problem.
Ja, die können ja meinem Telefonbuch gucken, wie sie das Wirtschaftsministerium erreichen. So, wir haben auch ein paar philosophische äh.
Hürden zu nehmen und zwar mit den äh jüngsten Entwicklungen in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und in der Europäischen Union. Und,
Deutschland oder die Bundesregierung möchte jetzt gerne.
Ein Register, Modernisierungsgesetz beschließen, beziehungsweise unser,
geliebter Innenminister Horst Seehofer hätte das sehr gerne und darin soll im Prinzip,
modernisiert werden, wie der Staat Daten sammelt spezifisch über Personen,
Und was hier vorgenommen wird oder was hier geplant wird, ist, dass in,
inzwischen oder in den benannt werden mehr als fünfzig unterschiedliche staatliche Datenbanken, die also zu den unterschiedlichsten Zwecken existieren, wo auch personenbezogene Daten drin sind.
Und es wurde im Jahr zweitausend,
neun, also ich glaube zweitausendneun eingeführt, Diskussion, die sind zweitausendsieben los, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe. Die Steuer-ID eingeführt
Ähm und zwar ist es so, man hat eine Steuernummer und jede einzelne Person der Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat auch eine Steuer-ID. Und diese Steuer-ID.
Ist dann Personen eindeutig und die bleibt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, auch immer gleich. Ja, im Gegensatz zu einer Steuernummer, wenn du das wenn du umziehst, das Finanzamt wechselst, kriegst du, glaube ich, auch eine neue Steuernummer. Weil die Steuernummer quasi,
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die aufgebaut sind, aber die lässt sich ihr einem Finanzamt zuordnen.
Richtig eine eine Steuernummer ist sozusagen nur so ein vorübergehender Link auf ein Finanzamt. Die Steuer-ID ist deine Identität.
Genau und da dann haben sie die eingeführt vor mehr als zehn Jahren,
Und da wurde schon gesagt, na, das ist nicht so gut, wenn ihr das macht, weil die Sorge besteht, dass ihr die später als einheitliche Person kennt, Ziffer missbrauchen könntet und
was jetzt vorgesehen ist im Rahmen der Registermodisierung, ist genau einfach die Steuer-ID,
einheitliche Person kennt Ziffer zu missbrauchen. Ähm das kennen wir zum Beispiel auch äh in den USA, wo es ja, wo ja die Social Security Number, also deine
Deine eigentliches Identifikationsmerkmal ist, ne? Du kannst dir irgendwie Ausweise, kannst dir überall ausstellen lassen, wo du mit einer ähm,
mit einer Geburtstagskunde vorbeigehst, kannst du in die staatliche Ausweise bekommen, die werden gibt's jetzt auch nicht den Personalausweis,
der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika soll Konzert im bei deinem Staat eine Drivers Lifestyle holen oder sowas, ne? Aber das, was sich wirklich innerhalb der USA
jeden Menschen identifizierbar macht, ist deine Social Security Number. Und wenn man jetzt also fünfzig unterschiedliche staatliche Datenbanken hat und,
hier zum Beispiel jetzt Personen drin sammelt, die im Laufe ihres Lebens vielleicht mal woanders gewohnt haben, dann lässt sich das eben nicht so ohne Weiteres zusammenführen.
Und das war auch genau das Ziel. Beispielsweise auch von äh bisherigen Urteilen des Bundesverfassungsgericht
Zum Beispiel bei Volksziele, zum Volksurteil, ja? Grade damit der Staat nicht alle Daten und Profile zusammenführt. Ähm.
Und das soll jetzt eben,
geschehen. Und die Sorge der Datenschützerinnen ist natürlich, jetzt muss man wieder sagen, ne, Datenschutz ist ja ein Abwehr,
Schutzrecht der Bürgerin gegenüber dem Staat. Ähm dass eben in Zukunft, ne, die Polizei nicht mehr sagt, wir haben, wir suchen Informationen zu Dinos Neumann-Wohnhaft in, sondern einfach in allen fünfzig staatlichen Datenbanken, von denen hier die Rede ist, einfach sagt, hier
das ist die Steuer-ID und dazu wollen wir jetzt mal bitte was. Und ähm jetzt.
Ist nicht in diesem Registermodernisierungsgesetz außerdem nicht ausgeschlossen, dass die Steuer-ID in der Privatwirtschaft dann auch verwendet wird, ja? Und,
es soll zum Beispiel auch dann der letzte Behördenkontakt einer Person immer gespeichert werden,
Ja, ich kann mir auch immer auch gute Gründe dafür vorstellen, so etwas zu machen und zu sagen, wann hammer ich das letzte Mal mit dem Kontakt gehabt? Lebt er überhaupt noch und so weiter, ne? Aber.
Gibt eben gute Gründe, genau das nicht zu tun. Und die Alternative, die von den Datenschützerinnen.
Vorgebracht wird, ist im Prinzip eine bereichsspezifische Kennzahl, um zu sagen, okay, im Bereich der Steuern hast du jetzt deine Steuer,
ID und im Bereich anderer,
was weiß ich, eine Strafverfolgung oder sonstwas hast du dann deine äh Insassen, kriminellen IT ähm und,
Hier gibt es also durchaus, ich glaube, verständliche ähm.
Vorbehalte. Insbesondere hat diese Vorbehalte auch der wissenschaftliche Dienst zusammengefasst und der zweifelt nämlich direkt an der Grundgesetzkompatibelität. Das hindert aber natürlich die Bundesregierung nicht, dass jetzt äh trotzdem.
Durchzusetzen und zwar mit der Begründung jetzt eine bereichspezifische Kennzahl, das wäre so ein bisschen zu teuer,
Also, also Grundgerichtskompatibilität ist ein bisschen zu teuer, da müssen wir drauf verzichten. Stattdessen
wird angebracht die Steuer-ID wird bereits heute in einer Vielzahl von Registern gespeichert so dass sie sich als Identifikator besonders gut eignet.
Meint die Regierung. Ja.
Deswegen heißt es ja auch ID.
Ja, aber Identifikator. Sie meinen Identifiker, ja, aber ich hach, ich denke, ich meine, äh man muss sich ja überlegen, wenn wenn es das jetzt gibt, am Ende gibt's nur einige wenige davon profitieren.
Und das äh ist dann sowas wie ein Zensus, ne. Polizeiermittlung.
Geheimdienste und sonstiges. Und ähm eigentlich wäre es schön, wenn sich die ganzen äh Reichsbürger und so äh dagegen wenden würden oder so. Also da könnten sie sich mal da hätten sie was, wo sie sich wirklich gegen,
wehren könnten mit mit Sinn und Verstand, aber.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist natürlich ein ein schwieriges Thema. Vielleicht sollte man noch eine Information nachlegen. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das so bewusst war, aber eine Steuer all die erhält man ja heutzutage schon mit der Geburt. Ne, also.
Ja, weil du halt auch erst nach zweitausendsieben geboren wurdest, aber äh seit ersten Juli zweitausendsieben gibt's diese Identifikationsnummer.
Wenige Zeit später dann auch irgendwann mein erstes Kind bekommen habe, hat dieses Kind quasi von Geburt an,
Steuer-IT.
Und hier hat man dann, die ist dann irgendwie auch definiert lebenslang und soll halt eigentlich nur äh immer dann verwendet werden, wenn sie eben um finanzielle Sachen geht, also wenn man mit der Finanzbehörde kommuniziert oder wenn man,
eben äh jetzt auch Bankgeschichten. Da fließt das jetzt sozusagen,
auch äh rein. Also für Kontoverbindung ist mittlerweile die Gabe dieser Identifikationsnummer glaube ich auch Pflicht. Und.
Ich will's mal kurz nur von der anderen Seite her aufziehen, ne? Nämlich so aus dieser Perspektive des Staates. Der, an dem wir ja auch andere,
ähm Anforderungen oder Wünsche haben, zum Beispiel wollen wir, dass so Steuerfluchtlöcher äh geschlossen werden. Wir wollen, dass irgendwie da effektiv Steuervermeidung,
nachgegangen wird. Äh zum Beispiel, ne? Oder generell halt einfach.
Soll ja der Staat auch in der Lage sein, sein ähm Gewaltmonopol, ja, also auch sein Entscheidungsgewaltmonopol quasi auch durchzusetzen, da wo es angemessen ist.
Und dann ist halt immer die Frage, wie hältst du die ganzen Andreas Müller und Peter Schmitz? Auseinander. Äh,
Ja, wenn wenn du nicht in irgendeiner Form ein identifizierendes äh Ding hast, also ich will nur sagen, aus der Logik einer Verwaltung, ja, vielleicht auch einer Regierung.
Ist das sinnvoll, da ein bisschen zu entschlacken?
Es ist absolut sinnvoll. Ich meine, du würdest ja keine Datenbank mit komplexen Daten anlegen, wo du irgendwie einen Überblick haben willst, ohne den wichtigen Items dort, all dies.
Zuzuweisen. Ja, also ist einfach.
Wäre einfach Quatsch, macht man nicht, ist die ganz normale Datenlogik. Man muss sich halt jetzt überlegen, wie kann man das,
zusammenbringen, diesen wünschenswerten Anspruch einer effizienten Verwaltung, die wir ja auch immer gerne haben möchten, ja, nebst auch äh der Möglichkeit, ähm dem Bürger ein guter Dienstleister zu sein.
Ist ja, wäre ja auch mal ganz geil. Wir wollen immer auch immer alles irgendwie online machen können und wir wollen immer alles einfach machen können,
ärgern uns über äh versendete Faxe und Warteschlangen, in den man stehen muss, also um so eine Digitalisierung des gesamten Behördenapparats zu realisieren, der mir ja letzten Endes auch Dienstleistungen erbringen soll,
nur so banale Sachen sein wie ein Auto anmelden in Berlin. Sehr schwierig. Ähm ja.
Kann ich sozusagen diesen Wunsch verstehen. Und ich denke, man muss an der Stelle auch mal eine kreative Diskussion aufmachen, wie man wie man dieses äh diesen grodischen Knoten da durchschlagen kann.
Würde ich mitgehen, ich denke also so ungefähr stelle ich mir das aber quasi vor, den Vorschlag der Bereichsspezifischen IT,
wo man also sagt, okay, ne, dann ist eben alles, was mit Steuer und dem ganzen Zinnova zu tun hat,
ist dann eben Steuer-ID, aber dann hast du eben für andere Bereiche, die damit wirklich nichts zu tun haben, eben eine andere ID. Am Ende würden sie die dann auch relativ simpel zusammenführen können, aber äh ja, also das das zumindest,
die Debatte um den Identifikator. Ich kann da dein deinen Aspekt auch verstehen und ich halte auch ohnehin ähm,
die staatliche Datensammlung im Moment nicht mehr für unser akutes Problem, ja. Ähm,
Zumindest in den staatlichen Registern. Ja, das hat ja jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt etwas damit zu tun, mit den Datensammlungen der Geheimdienste und der Polizei, die sonst noch irgendwie so anfallen. Da haben wir nämlich ja auch äh in der letzten
Folge schon darüber gesprochen, dass es da um äh.
Eine neue Ermöglichung im.
Ähm im europäischen Bereich gehen soll, der Strafverfolgung und zwar, dass im weitesten Sinne eindringen in,
die äh Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation. Und in der letzten Folge haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass es da dieses,
White Paper gab, bei dem mehrere ähm Konzepte diskutiert wurden.
Wie Messenger-Anbieter ähm quasi ein, also Inhaltefilter implementieren können für die,
Dateien oder Inhalte, die du über diesen Messenger tauscht, ohne tatsächlich Einblick in die Kommunikation zu erlangen. Und das ist natürlich,
auch ein eine Art gordischer Knoten, eine Art ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, aber da wurden,
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht eben so Sachen, diskutiert wie, ja, jede Datei kann man ja haschen und dann gegen eine Datenbank prüfen und was da nicht alles für Ideen kam. So, da hat sich ähm Ralf Bend bei uns in den Kommentaren gemeldet, ähm,
der,
sich gewünscht hat und das hat er zurecht getan, dass wir jetzt auch mal würdigen, was die äh die Kommission, die Europäische Kommunikation,
Meine Güte, die europäische Kommission ähm da tatsächlich für einen Gesetzesvorschlag eingebracht haben, hat.
Und ähm dafür auch äh vielen Dank an Ralph, der da nochmal drauf hingewiesen hat, dass man das mal genau lesen muss. So und zwar ist das, was die Kommission da jetzt vorbringt
Ähm im Prinzip die,
gehen von dem Zustand aus, dass es bereits einige Anbieter von Kommunikationsdiensten gibt, die derartige Scanning auf die eine oder die andere Weise.
Implementiert haben. Die Technologien dafür haben. Und sie stellen jetzt also fest, dass sie das grundsätzlich gut finden,
solange das nicht die tatsächliche Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung irgendwie nachhaltig vollständig kaputt macht. Und stellen aber fest.
Dass das eine ähm Verletzung der E-Privacy-Direktive darstellen kann, weshalb sie jetzt sagen, sie wollen eine temporäre Abweichung von,
bestimmten Aspekten der E-Privacy-Direktive vereinbaren.
Und das sind, das formulieren sie in in vier relativ kurzen Artikeln. Der erste ist, diese Ausnahme gilt nur und ausschließlich um,
eben also dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch und ihn damit in Zusammenhang stecken steckendes Material zu entfernen.
In Artikel zwei definieren Sie, für welche Services das gilt und was material ist und in dem Artikel drei sagen Sie quasi ist,
die eigentliche Kern des Gesetzes, wo sie sagen, okay, also eine begrenzte Ausnahme von den Pflichten, die nämlich durch die Artikel fünf Absatz eins und sechs der E-Privacy Direktive äh,
existieren für die Verarbeitung von persönlichen Daten und Daten in Verbindung mit der Bereitstellung dieses,
nummerunabhängigen Interpersonal, den Kommunikationsdienstes, wie sieht das dort nennen? Also wir haben da wieder die den Bezug zu dem schönen Begriff, den wir gerade schon hatten, die,
Nummern vermittelten Dienst oder was auch immer das ist, ja? Und da sagen sie, okay ähm.
Inklusive, dass Menschen da rein blicken ähm,
Würden sie äh eine Ausnahme machen für den einzigen Zweck eben diesen dieses äh online zu erkennen.
Und,
die Meldung an Strafverfolgung und Organisationen, die im öffentlichen Interesse gegen dieses Material eintreten zu melden,
und es eben auch zu entfernen. So und dann sagen sie aber dafür müssen Bedingungen,
Apple, sein erstens, die die erste Bedingung ist die Verarbeitung ist angemessen und begrenzt auf,
gut etablierte Technologien, spezifisch, dass
ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum sie dieses White Paper angefordert haben, wo eben die unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten diskutiert werden. Ja, und zu sagen, okay, was ist denn hier Propossionet und was ist hier? Da wurden ja drei
ähm Technologien am Ende als äh ja Lösungskandidatinnen äh hervorgehoben. Dann sagen.
Welche drei waren das?
Ähm das waren im Prinzip immer die mit äh die mit hashion und Doppelblind gearbeitet haben, ne, also wo du nicht den verrätst, ähm,
oder wo in einem TPM die Prüfung stattfindet. Ich gucke mal, habe ich das Dokument noch aufm Desktop? Also diejenigen, die wirklich, ja, wo man schon noch argumentieren kann.
Hier verrätst du allenfalls ob du ein spezifisches Material hast, aber nichts über die anderen Materialien, die du hast. Das war also eine der entscheidenden Kenngrößen. Dann,
Zweite Bedingung, das muss ausreichend rediabel sein, das ist,
jegliche Fehlentscheidung zu dem größten Maß eingrenzt, ja? Ähm.
Es darf, es muss begrenzt sein auf die Verwendung relevanter Indikatoren, also ich glaube, damit ist so gemein sein, es muss quasi, darf nicht mehr Daten erfassen als spezifisch notwendig und relevant sind. Ähm.
Die Verarbeitung ist begrenzt auf den Teil, der eben dringend notwendig ist und der Anbieter muss ein ein jährlichen Bericht ähm,
veröffentlichen darüber, wie diese Datenverarbeitung funktioniert. Äh Typ und äh Menge an Daten, die verarbeitet wurden, die Anzahl der Fälle, die auf diese Weise identifiziert wurden, die ähm angewandten Maßnahmen,
um diese
auszuwählen und zu verbessern, ähm Anzahlen und Verhältnisse für Fehler, also Falls positives der der unterschiedlichen Technologie, die angewendet werden.
Und ähm wie lange Daten gespeichert werden. Also im Prinzip, sie müssen sehr genau darüber Auskunft geben, wie diese äh Technologien,
funktionieren und in Artikel vier wird dann einfach nur gesagt, okay, ab wann das äh äh Gesetz werden kann. Also.
Jetzt musst du natürlich schon sagen, das heißt, das ist alles nicht, dass die Kommission jetzt vorschreiben würde, dass jeder Anbieter so etwas machen muss, sondern sie sagen, du darfst das, aber selbst wenn du es machst, gibt es sehr strenge Bedingungen. Und da muss man schon ähm.
Natürlich finde ich's trotzdem nicht gut, wenn es so etwas gibt. Und ich glaube auch, dass äh ich sehe hier
das Risiko, dass diese Bedingungen natürlich aufgeweicht werden und von dem du darfst das machen, irgendwann ein. Du musst es machen, wird und äh wenn wenn es eh alle machen, ist dann die nächste Regulation gibt, die sagt übrigens auch für,
Terror und haste nicht gesehen und Wettbetrug und Drogenhandel, ne, dass sowas halt auch alles noch kommt, aber dieser eine Gesetzesvorschlag ist zumindest nicht.
Direkt zu kritisieren, als ein staatlicher oder EU-Ebene Angriff auf verschlüsselte Kommunikation, äh sondern eben ja,
die Ermöglichung.
Und je nachdem wie man blickt, stark ist eingrenzen eines solchen Angriffs. Das ändert natürlich trotzdem nichts daran, dass,
diese Maßnahmen allenfalls dafür da sind, eben von den jeweiligen Plattformen. Die Leute und den Austausch dieses Materials zu verdrängen oder zu verhindern, ähm wie wir eben wissen,
bedienen sich diese Täter eben auch anderer Infrastrukturen als WhatsApp. Außer sie sind, wie heißt dieser dämliche Fußballer da?
Tär dämliche Fußballer. Da gibt's viele zur Aus.
Ja also der gerade der, der sich verantworten muss, weil er irgendwie Leuten.
Ach so, ähm ja ähm.
Mit Zelda, war dat, wart ihr das?
Ja, der hat auf jeden Fall, der hat diese Materialien ja unaufgefordert an an Dritte geschickt. Wo du dich auch fragst.
Metzelder.
Du denn? Irgendwie so, hm, was mache ich denn heute? Ah, am besten äh schicke ich jetzt einfach mal Illegales, Perverses Material, an irgendwelche Frauen, die ich nicht kenne.
Das ist auch ein sehr ähm.
Ja, da fragt man sich auch, was da wo gelaufen sein mag?
Will man vielleicht gar nicht wissen, ne?
Nee, das will ich auch nicht wissen.
Okay, aber danke Ralf für den Hinweis, äh diese EU-Texte sind immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu lesen, aber da hattest du Recht, den sollte ich mir mal angucken.
Wir haben außerdem hier, ich wollte jetzt nur, das ist eher so eine kurze Meldung. Wir haben ja hier im Logbuch Netzpolitik schon sehr früh, auch über Immunitätsausweise gesprochen und in dem äh YouTube-Format mit.
Lea, der Lokbo, dem Lokboo Freiheit, haben wir auch über den Immunitätsausweis gesprochen, im, im Mai dieses Jahres schon, da wurde jetzt der Ethikrat, hat sich jetzt dazu geäußert, äh, und sagt, ja, halten Sie für 'ne schlechte Idee,
wer hätte das gedacht? Haben wir damals schon gesagt, hätte man uns gefragt, hätten sich das.
Ja, aber gut, ich meine, in der Corona-Hotel äh Folge sind wir ja,
haben wir zumindest nochmal diesen Gedanken durchgespielt, was wäre denn, wenn so eine Immunität zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen werden kann? Und es äh gibt vor allem extrem,
starke Bedenken. Rein auf medizinischer Natur, äh wie denn Immunität überhaupt nachgewiesen werden kann. Also es ist ja vieles immer noch nicht verstanden.
Rund um den Coronavirus, aber was sich jetzt schon so ein bisschen abzeichnet, ist, dass das mit dieser äh mit diesem Nachweis von Immunität über Antikörper eine sehr wackelige Geschichte ist, weil einfach Leute da komplett aus dem Radar gehen
ihre Körper halt einfach diese Signale nicht mehr bringen, was nicht unbedingt heißt, dass sie nicht immun sind, ja, das können sie dann tatsächlich noch irgendwie sein, nur,
lässt sich das eben nicht sehr zuverlässig messen.
Jetzt hat hier aber glaube ich der Ethikrat nicht unbedingt davon abgeraten, äh weil sich das nicht zuverlässig messen lässt, weil es ist ja der Ethikerinnenrat und nicht der Medizinerinnenrat.
Weiß nicht, wie der besetzt ist. Wird ja sicherlich nicht frei von Medizinern sein, oder?
Ob sie sinnvoll sind haben die beurteilt, ethisch vertretbar, fair und sicher umsetzbar. Die Mitglieder raten,
einhellig von solchen Bescheinigungen ab. Äh sie begründen das so, na doch, tatsächlich,
genau dein Kernargument, es lässt sich nicht, verlässlich nachweisen, dass und wie lange ein genesene Person immun ist,
Entscheidend ist dabei der Zusatz zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt. Denn es ist zu erwarten, dass sich der medizinische Sachstand ändert, ja.
Für diesen Fall würde zumindest ein Teil der Ratsmitglieder seine Ablehnung aufgeben. Also sie haben,
potenzielle Neubewertung des Sachverhalts in Aussicht gestellt, wenn sich die medizinische oder die wissenschaftliche Grundlage dazu ändert.
Bescheinigung muss fälschungssicher sein. Ich denk, ah ich hätte jetzt gehofft, dass ein äh Immunitäts äh ein ein äh Ethikrat,
sich ein bisschen mehr damit auseinandersetzen würde, was das äh bedeutet für den Zeitpunkt, wo,
nicht alle immun sind. Es wird irgendwann einen Zeitpunkt übrigens geben, letztens in einem Gespräch mit einer äh Journalistin so,
da habe ich auch so ein bisschen mit meinen philosophischen Hürden gerungen.
Festgestellt, es wird irgendwann einen Moment geben in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, wo die Hälfte der Menschen immun ist und die andere Hälfte nicht.
Also hoffentlich, hoffentlich kommen wir wenigstens an den Punkt, ne? Und ähm das wird so eine richtig blöde Zeit.
Nicht, dass die Zeit jetzt noch nicht blöd wäre, also,
blöd ist eh und die könnte auch in den nächsten Wochen noch viel blöder werden.
Aber ähm ja, schauen wir mal, was äh so kommt. Also, ist ein bisschen müßig,
ähm das jetzt schon irgendwie vorauszusagen. Wir werden sicherlich noch die eine oder andere Katastrophe verbinden müssen dieses Jahr, bevor dann endlich die goldenen Zwanziger kommen. Minus.
Ja, ja, ich bin da gespannt, ähm da äh höre ich dich ja immer noch.
Die goldenen Zwanziger haben auch neunzehnhundertzwanzig nicht Anfang der der Dekade angefangen. Das war dann halt erst ein paar Jahre später. Erst.
Mal sagen können, als du mich hier heiß gemacht.
Es wurde erst schlimmer, bevor es viel besser wurde. Wobei es da nachher dann noch schlimmer wurde. Aber das ist eine andere.
Aber dann noch mal viel besser wieder.
Ja, aber das dauert noch ein bisschen, ne. Müssen wir noch müssen noch ein paar lebensverlängernde Maßnahmen, glaube ich, einleiten, dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Okay, du wolltest uns ein bisschen was zum Zero-Rating. Zero-Reading.
Genau.
Es gibt heiße, heiße Informationen in deiner, in deiner Umgebung, nämlich in deiner Europa. Äh es begab sich äh äh zu einer Zeit in Ungarn,
dass ein Telekommunikationsanbieter verklagt wurde, namens Telen Noah und der hatte nämlich zwei Pakete äh quasi so als Nulltarif äh verkauft.
Ja, das schon. Also ein Zero rated Tarif, wo eben bestimmte Dienste, weiß jetzt nicht welche,
nicht auf den Datenverbrauch angerechnet wurden.
Und dieses Thema äh hatten wir ja nun hier auch schon äh häufiger. Thomas hat ja sehr viel darüber berichtet, nicht nur berichtet, sondern vor allem auch auf europäischer Ebene ganz erheblich dazu beigetragen
dass wir eigentlich eine Verordnung haben über Neutralität, die, na ja, irgendwie das eigentlich so verhindern sollte.
Aber am Ende haben sich dann alle erstmal gedacht, so ja, mir doch egal, was da drin steht, ich äh mache das jetzt einfach mal so,
und äh da gehörte dann auch Tillenor dazu. Und jetzt dauerte es eben eine Weile,
und es wurde dagegen geklagt in Ungarn.
Äh und äh dann kamen die ungarischen Behörden für Medien und Telekommunikation,
so zu dem Schluss, dass dieses Angebot, was sie dort haben gegen Artikel drei, Absatz drei dieser Verordnung, denn es ist Neutralitätsverordnung,
verstößt, ja? Das ist die äh der Artikel, der quasi versucht zu sichern, die Pflicht zugleichen und nicht diskriminierenden Behandlung des Verkehrs,
Und daraufhin hat dann Tillenoa äh zurückgeklagt und das quasi auf die höchste nationale Ebene gehoben,
ungarische Gerichtshof hat dann das Ganze an den europäischen Gerichtshof weitergeleitet. Wir hatten das ja auch schon einige Male.
Vor allem in den Gesprächen mit Max und so weiter kam das, glaube ich, zur Sprache auch an anderen Stellen,
Der EUGH ist nichts an den man sich wendet, sondern der EUGH ist etwas, was nur jeweils die höchste gerichtliche Ebene in,
einem Mitgliedstaat äh Mitgliedsstaat der Europäischen Union ähm,
sich dorthin genau anrufen kann, da sagen kann, hier hör mal, hier geht's irgendwie um europäische Belange, hier ist eine Verordnung, hier ist eine Richtlinie betroffen
Wir sehen uns nicht in Stande des abschließend zu beurteilen. Wir hätten ja jetzt gerne mal Klärung.
Und genau das ist jetzt hier passiert und der EuGH hat jetzt hier äh auch einen Beschluss gefasst.
Und das ist quasi überhaupt das erste Mal, dass über diese Verordnung der Netzneutralität durch den EuGH äh,
irgendeine Aussage getroffen wurde. Das ist das erste Mal, dass sie quasi dieses Gesetz auch tatsächlich mal ausgelegt haben. Na ja und äh,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Sie haben jetzt äh geurteilt und meinten, die finden das jetzt nicht so geil,
so gemacht hätte, weil das führe ja zu einer erheblichen Einschränkung der Ausübung der Rechte der Endnutzer,
und könne daher den Kern dieser Rechte untergraben.
Und ähm ja, das bedeutet äh im Kern, dass hier das EuGH die Position einnimmt, dass diese Zero-Rating-Tarife von so mit dieser äh Verordnung auf europäischer Ebene
nicht zusammen gehen. Das Ganze ist jetzt sozusagen eine eine Vorabentscheidung des europäischen Rechts äh und.
Ähm das wird jetzt vermutlich in Ungarn zur Folge haben, dass dieser Tarif einfach,
so durchgeführt werden kann, sondern anders aufgestellt sein muss. Und ähm das ist aber letzten Endes immer noch eine nationale Aufgabe. Also es ist nicht so, dass jetzt dieser EuGH Gerichtsspruch,
automatische Rechtsprechung in Ungarn ist, sondern das geht jetzt sozusagen mit dieser Empfehlung, geht es jetzt quasi an den ungarischen Gerichtshof und dann müssen die selber machen, aber man kann sich jetzt äh vorstellen, wie das ausgeht. Wobei in Ungarn weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau,
Ob das dann sozusagen auch so kommt, ne? Anderes Ding.
Ähm und die Entscheidung, wenn sie dann auch erstmal gemacht hat, ist aber jetzt im Prinzip auch für andere nationale Gerichte in Europa,
maßgeblich und kann eben auch herangezogen werden. Und wir haben ja die Situation, dass die Bundesnetzagentur auch Stream on angemahnt hat, wegen,
Also die die Telekom angebahnt hat, wegen dieses Stream-Orden-Tarifs, der genau das Gleiche ist, ja, da gibt's auch ein Zero-Rating,
zahlreiche Sachen auf der einen Seite und eben auch das runterdrosseln von äh anderen Streams
und ähm im ersten Schritt ist ja auch die Beschwerde der Bundesnetzagentur auch hat ja auch sofort gegriffen, also dieses EU-Roaming, also das ist die Telekom saß ich ja schon gezwungen
Angebot auch auf gesamt Europa auszudehnen das war ja anfangs nur innerhalb von Deutschland in ihrem eigenen Netz,
Ja und jetzt wird man halt sehen, ob da äh was passiert. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob's jetzt hier schon irgendjemand geben kann in Deutschland, der einfach in diesem Fall das automatisch da drauf bezieht. Oder ob es jetzt nochmal erforderlich ist, dass,
hier irgendwie geklagt wird, keine Ahnung, das wird sicherlich Thomas demnächst irgendwie mal erzählen können.
Alles klar.
Sieht aber so aus, als ob Zero-Rating jetzt äh auf dem Weg nach draußen ist in Europa.
Ja, wäre schön, also natürlich, was jetzt passieren wird, ist, die Anbieter werden sagen, äh die nehmen die die Europa nehmen euch irgendwie die schönen äh kostenlosen Angebote weg, die wir euch geben wollen. Der Fakt ist aber,
Nein, die sorgen nur dafür, dass halt alles so günstig wird, ne? Weil jede Bevorteiligung von bestimmten Datenverkehr ist eben eine Benachteiligung des anderen und ähm insbesondere bei diesem Stream-On ist es ja,
tatsächlich so, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so einen Telekom-Vertrag hättest, wo du mal äh Stream on Social und Stream on äh,
Video und Musik und was da alles anklicken kannst, dann bleibt am Ende noch wenig Internet über.
Was auf dein Datenvolumen angerechnet wird, mit anderen Worten, die können jetzt nicht mehr argumentieren, sie bräuchten dieses,
dieses Distinktionsmerkmal des Datenvolumens um ihr Netz sich zu überlasten, weil dann dürften sie den Leuten nicht Netflix kostenlos geben, ne? Und nicht aufs Datenvolumen anrechnen. Weil das ballert natürlich,
in das Volumen rein und das wird mit Sicherheit nicht. Also mit dem Rest wirst du das Netz jetzt nicht mehr überlasten,
Ähm insofern ja, wäre das schon sehr schön ähm.
Ja, einfach Flatrate für alle, macht das über die, macht das macht das über die Geschwindigkeit, nicht über das Datenvolumen, ja? Da kann ich ja irgendwie noch mit leben. Dann sagst du, ja, ich zahle, aber für die und die Geschwindigkeit das äh ist eine andere Geschichte.
Okay, dann haben wir ich wollte ja mal, also das ist wieder so ein Thema von dem wir nicht so so viel zu tun haben. Aber,
wollte es trotzdem mal erwähnen, weil es ja doch schon sehr,
unterhaltsam ist, was in diesem Bereich in Deutschland gerade passiert ist, denn es gab in Nordrhein-Westfalen, in Mühlheim an der Ruhr eine,
mehrere Verhaftungen oder und Hausdurchsuchungen bei Polizistinnen.
Und Polizisten, die unter dem Verdacht stehen, über Jahre rechtsextremistische Propaganda in privaten Chatgruppen verschickt und empfangen zu haben. So Hakenkreuze, ähm Ausländer,
feindliche und ausländerverächtliche Schätzchen, Bilder von Hitler und was die sich da alles hin und her geschickt haben,
Ähm und dann, das muss ich, das muss ich eigentlich tatsächlich wirklich direkt aus dem Spiegel zitieren, weil das also
Tim, Vorsicht, ne? Nee, also das wird jetzt richtig
hart für dein Herz. Ja, ich weiß, dass du ja nah am Wasser gebaut bist und dass das unter Umständen dein dein zartes, emotionales Gerüst auch so schwer erschüttern kann wie meins. Ja.
Ich habe schon, ich habe schon ein bisschen äh schweißnasse Hände bekommen, also Hitler-Bildchen gesagt hast.
Ja, aber jetzt pass auf, jetzt haben wir also diese, bei diesen Polizistinnen und Polizisten.
Hausdurchsuchung gemacht. Am Mittwoch wurden die Wohnungen und Dienststellen der Beschuldigten durchsucht. Nach Spiegelinformationen sollen die Einsatzkräfte dabei in mehreren Fällen
psychosoziale Unterstützung angefordert haben. Manche Beschuldigte und deren Angehörige sollen
die Situation rund um die Durchsuchung nicht verkraftet und einen Zusammenbruch erlitten haben, sogenannte PS
U-Teams sollen deshalb hinzugeworfen worden sein.
Psychosozial.
Psychosoziale Unterstützung wahrscheinlich. Da muss ich sagen, da gibt's also von uns wirklich eine große Runde Mitleid. Das tut mir richtig leid.
Nee, da gibt's, da gibt's sogar einen Award für, gibt's den äh original Logbuch Netzpolitik, Schneeflocken Award für oder?
Schneeflocken wird traditionell im Winter übergeben in Form eines Schneeballs, den ich vor drei Jahren gemacht habe und im Eisfach aufbewahrt habe.
Aber da.
So und der wird.
Wegen Corona, ne? Da musste aus der Ferne.
Aus der Ferne muss ich dann leider werfen. So und hinten also was ist das für eine? Da,
was weißt du? Jahrelang irgendwelche Nazigruppen unterhalten, ne? Aber wenn dann mal die äh die Sturmtruppen bei dir vor der Tür stehen, ne, dann ist das Gehäu auf einmal groß, ne.
Unglaublich. Also das finde ich das wirklich unsere emotionale Zusammenbrüche bei der Hausdurchsuchung, ne. Ist doch Routine, das kennen die doch. Unglaublich, oder? Also ich finde das, darf ich so nur ganz wenig Mitleid
muss ich tatsächlich sagen, nennen mich Arthur, Tim. Aber ich habe nur wenig Mitgleid mit denen.
Mensch, Mensch, Mensch. Dass du da keine, dass du da keine philosophischen Vorbehalte hast.
So, jetzt muss ich aber auch äh das Thema muss natürlich schon so ein bisschen eingeordnet werden.
Denn was ja der eigentliche Aufreger ist, dass sich unser Innenminister ähm ja seit längerer Zeit dagegen weigert, mal eine Untersuchung.
Anzustrengen
was ist wie das so aussieht mit Rechtsradikalen Werthaltung und Ausländerfeindlichkeit bei der Polizei. Und die Argumente die er dafür anbringt sind ja spannend, ne? Also schöne Argumente.
Ja, Lino ist, das passt einfach nicht in sein, das ist einfach nicht in seiner Philosophie. Äh ja.
Ist nicht in seiner Philosophie, ne, aber sein Kernargument ist ja sein Kernargument ist ja tatsächlich, dass ähm,
dass die Polizei unter Generalverdacht stellen würde. Was ich richtig geil finde,
ich meine, kannst ja mal die Mühlheimer Polizei fragen in Mühlheim an der Ruhr, äh wen diese, ob die gegen irgendjemanden Generalverdacht hegen würden in ihrer Nazi-Chat-Gruppe, ne.
Nee. Alle.
Nein, nein, nein. Bei uns sind alle Deutschen gleich. So und das.
Ja
Wir haben nichts gegen Fremde, aber diese Fremden sind nicht von hier, ne? Also es ist so dieses typische okay, aber ähm nee, tatsächlich und ich würde da jetzt ganz gerne äh nachdem wir jetzt lange genug darüber geschätzt haben, mal ein paar ernste Worte zu sagen,
Und zwar ähm kenne ich tatsächlich,
Polizisten in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Äh die auch im Mühlheim an der Ruhr ist ja wie der Name schon sagt, im Ruhrgebiet äh und ich kenne
Leute, die bei der Polizei im Ruhrgebiet waren oder auch noch sind. Und was die mir über ihre,
tägliche Erfahrungen schildern, wenn sie eben ähm Streifendienst sind, ist, dass sie tatsächlich,
Ja, ich meine, das sind,
Polizisten, die auf der Straße herumlaufen oder eben Streife fahren und zu den Situationen geholt werden, zu denen Polizei nun mal gerufen wird, ja? Und es ist,
tatsächlich ja so, dass ein größerer Teil der Bevölkerung nie mit der Polizei zu tun hat.
Und bestimmte Teile der Bevölkerung oft. Und diese Teile der Bevölkerung sind in der Regel die gesellschaftlich Benachteiligten,
Weil die gesellschaftlich benachteiligten, auch irgendwie den Tag rumkriegen müssen, auch irgendwie,
ein Einkommen versuchen müssen, zu erzielen und je stärker sie benachteiligt sind, desto stärker sind auch ihre Möglichkeiten. Ähm
eingeschränkt, das zu tun. Ähm
Beispielsweise haben wir hier in Berlin auch einige ähm Orte, die relativ bekannt sind, dafür, dass dort auch,
Gruppierungen von ähm vermutlich ausländischen Personen. Ähm Drogenhandel betreiben.
Ähm diese Menschen haben aber tatsächlich,
in den meisten Fällen auch gar keine andere Möglichkeit. Ein Einkommen in irgendeiner Form zu bestreiten, weil sie hier keine dauerhaften Aufenthalts und Arbeitsgenehmigungen haben, ähm,
weil sie äh ja, keine äh nennenswerten Integrationsunterstützung bekommen, ja? Äh wir kennen diese Fälle von Leuten, die äh,
Geflüchtete ausbilden und dann werden die ihn weggenommen und abgeschoben. Ja, all solche äh Geschichten kennen wir alles und.
Es gehört natürlich zu den notwendigen,
sozialen Kompetenz einer Polizistin, die in derartigen Einsätze und derartigen Gebieten der Kriminalität tätig ist, davon zu abstrahieren,
zu erkennen, aha, hier, ne, ich gehe auf die Arbeit, ne? Und da habe ich jetzt hauptsächlich mit ähm.
Oder habe ich zu einem vermehrten Teil mit Ausländer Personen zu tun, ausländischen Personen zu tun, als ich es sonst habe,
Ja und das sind dann in dem und ich bin im Bereich der Kleinkriminalität tätig. Ich habe die Ladendiebe sind irgendwie, da sind mehr Ausländer drunter, als was weiß ich. Äh ich in meinem Freundeskreis finde. Ja und,
von dieser Erfahrung zu abstrahieren,
und die tatsächlichen gesellschaftlichen Hintergründe sich vor Augen zu halten, das ist niemandem,
von Gott gegeben, das erfordert eine,
Bewusstmachung der gesellschaftlichen Verhältnisse, eine Reflexion der eigenen Rolle und eben auch der Situation, in der sich die Menschen dort befinden.
Und wenn unsere Polizei, und da bin ich mir relativ sicher, nur zu einem geringen Teil.
Zu dieser Reflexion in der Lage ist, dann liegt das nicht an diesen Polizistinnen und Polizisten, sondern dann liegt das daran, wie sie geführt werden, wie sie in ihren Beruf eingebracht werden, wie sie ähm.
Welche Schulungen sie bekommen, welche äh Leitmodelle sie bekommen. Und ich glaube,
Das ist das, wofür sie, wovor sich ähm Horst Seehofer und alle Innenminister ähm,
so sorgen müssen, dass dass natürlich in der Polizei
nicht dafür gesorgt wird, dass da ähm reflektierte äh Personen mit relativ geringen philosophischen Hürden in ihrer eigenen Arbeit äh tätig sind
die also sich ihrer gesellschaftlichen Wirkung bewusst sind und nicht eine größere Frustration erleiden, äh weil sie sich irgendwie in in ihrem gefährlichen Job irgendwie allein gelassen fühlen oder äh
ja, keine Einordnung. Ihr wird nicht dabei geholfen bei der Einordnung dessen, was sie da,
tun. Und das glaube ich, dass es schon auch eine ähm ein Versagen der der politischen Führung.
Ja, zumal das ja auch jetzt so ein Aspekt ist, wo man nicht sagen kann, das ist jetzt ein spezifisches Problem der deutschen Polizei derzeit.
Generelles Problem, also gar nicht mal nur der Polizei, aber speziell natürlich der Polizei an sich, also das Prinzip, Polizei bringt das so mit sich. Und deswegen muss das äh Teil,
sein, äh dessen wie eine Polizei.
Wird, so wie auch andere spezifische Bereiche des Staates, ähm.
Ja, da auch andere Sensibilitäten aufweisen muss. Es betrifft genauso auch, was weiß ich, die Arbeits,
Agentur zum Beispiel überhaupt soziale Dienste die es ja sozusagen auch immer eigentlich fast jeder Bereich hat irgendwie so spezifischen Blick auf die auf die Gesellschaft nur in dem Moment.
Wo es auf die Polizei kommt, reden wir nämlich auch von der konkreten Auslegung von Gesetzen und eben auch äh der Auslegung von angemessenen Gegenmaßnahmen gegen irgendein äh wahrgenommen, falsches Verhalten,
Na ja und wir sehen ja nun leider sehr, dass sich so ein gewisser ich meine man wenn die jetzt in so Nazigruppen,
WhatsApp-Gruppen da irgendwie einfach die ganze Zeit sich einfach nur noch über Ausländer und eigentlich alle anderen, die nicht so sind wie sie, ja, was im Prinzip auch heißt, alle, die nicht Polizisten sind, auslassen.
Dann läuft er einfach was schief. So und dann hat man dagegen vorzugehen und dann ist es eigentlich scheißegal, ob da jetzt irgendjemand,
vielleicht unter Umständen, unter Generalverdacht stellt, ja, dann sollten sie halt dafür sorgen, dass hier nur die richtigen verdächtigt werden, indem man mal genau nachschaut, weil ich bin mir auch sicher, dass es,
vielleicht sogar auch zahlreiche, vielleicht sogar auch die Mehrheit der Polizisten das anders sehen.
Oder sehen wollen. Ja, oder sich teilweise schon als Minderheit fühlen, weil sie eigentlich von so einer lautstarken,
anderen Minderheit so ein bisschen klein gehalten werden wie wir das ja auch ansonsten in sozialen Gruppen sehen, in Familien sehen. Und,
Diese Leute gehören gestärkt und diese Leute muss irgendwie ähm die Möglichkeit geben, sowas auch anschwärzen zu können, wenn sie das sehen. Ohne jetzt gleich selber wieder so als Verräter dahingestellt zu werden und ausgeschlossen zu werden
Ist ja auch generell schwierig für Polizisten. Meine nicht, dass ich da jetzt viel Eindruck Einblick hätte, aber,
Ist immer so ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung.
Polizisten tendieren dazu, auch in ihrem normalen sozialen Leben jenseits des Berufs viel mit Polizisten zu tun zu haben.
Auch so ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat.
Dass niemand was mit Polizisten zu tun haben will. Ja.
Ist das, ist das so.
Wer will schon? Wer hat schon gern die Polizei im Haus?
Ja, weil aber auch das ist ja schon schlimm genug, weil,
das ja sozusagen auch schon so ein grundlegendes Misstrauen äh zeigt, ja so dass du denkst so, ja, nee, weiß ich nicht, also mit Polizisten trete ich mir halt irgend so eine Nazitruppe ein,
Wenn's das nicht ist, halt generell so ein ähm.
Gar nicht mal so, dass jetzt jeder unbedingt was zu befürchten hätte oder das Polizisten nicht generell auch irgendwie äh einen Unterschied machen können zwischen.
Was es jetzt irgendwie angemessen und was ist nicht angemessen? Ist ja auch nicht so, dass die jetzt den ganzen Tag auf der Straße stehen und jeden gleichen Bau schicken, der bei rot über die Ampel geht,
Aber wenn da halt bei rot über die Ampel gehst und dabei irgendwie äh den Polizeiwagen, der einen Adapter besteht, irgendwie noch einen Finger zeigst, so.
Auch noch. Das Problem ist, wenn die falsche Hautfarbe hast.
Gut. Oder das falsche Tattoo, ja.
Also ich ich denke, dass.
Ein Staat gut beraten ist, diesen sich dieser sehr offensichtlichen ähm.
Und auch leicht erklärbaren Phänomene des Polizeiberufs bewusst zu sein und hier aktiv,
gegenzusteuern. Und was, was mir gerade Sorge macht, ist zum Beispiel, na, also in in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, also Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben da haben sie auch festgestellt, dass die Polizei auch Nazis sind, ja? Hatten dann in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern herausgefunden,
Wer hätte damit rechnen können? Und ähm.
Jetzt sagt halt äh der Innenminister Lorenz Caffier, er will Rechtsextreme äh Strukturen innerhalb der Polizei konsequent aufarbeiten. So jetzt was dann passieren wird, ist und das ist muss ich auch sagen, wahrscheinlich das andere Problem,
was der Seehofer da tatsächlich auch fühlt, wenn die da jetzt.
Den Eindruck gewinnen, dass sie noch nicht einmal den Rückhalt ihrer äh ihres äh oberen Dienstherren haben, äh dann wird es sicherlich nicht zu einer Frustrationsminderung bei den äh Polizistinnen,
führen. Insofern denke ich,
man muss hier von der Regierungsseite, von der Seite eines Innenministers die Verantwortung erkennen, diesen Tendenzen nachhaltig entgegen zu wirken und das bedeutet, dem Polizeiberuf so zu gestalten.
Dass diesen Tendenzen entgegengewirkt wird und nicht erst dann
wenn man feststellt, OK das sind jetzt Voll-Nazis und die haben 'ne WhatsApp-Gruppe, jetzt ziehen wir die aus dem Verkehr, ja? Das glaube ich, ist einfach auch falsches Management, dieses,
nachvollziehbaren Problems, in dem Moment, wo du sagst, du machst eine Polizei. Äh auf jeden Fall finde ich daher diese Nachricht sehr gut
die ich ähm in der Zeitung der Postillon,
gelesen habe. Es werden jetzt also in den nächsten Monaten bundesweit viertausend Antifa-Mitglieder eingestellt, um ein Gegengewicht zu den Rechtsextremen Beamten in den eigenen Reihen zu bilden, der das,
könnte also Herbert Royal äh Innenminister von,
Nordrhein-Westfalen sagte, wir versuchen lieber, die Polizei wieder in die Mitte der Gesellschaft zu schieben, indem wir gezielt Linksextremisten anwerben.
Wenn man jetzt mit der Antifa Familika äh vorspricht.
Die kannst du jetzt äh äh in einem einmaligen Tauschangebot direkt gegen Polizeidienstausweis tauschen. Und du behältst deine Bonuspunkte.
Ach, wow, geil.
Und also äh du gibst aber kein Demogeld mehr, ne. Also am Wochenende aber dann halt vom Staat.
Ach so, dann zahlen die natürlich nicht, weil dann zahlst ja der Staat sozusagen das Geld.
Das ist dann weg, ja.
Ja okay, dann läuft ja letztlich aufs Gleiche raus.
Und du darfst bewaffnet hingehen.
Vermummt und mit Schild und mit.
Alles also es ist wirklich ein Upgrade, ja? Es ist wirklich, es ist, du hast einfach direkt ein ganz anderes status level.
Nicht mehr mit der Straßenbahn. Schön im Sixpack hingefahren werden. Das läuft. Geil.
Ja. Okay.
Es gibt Leute, die können den Eindruck bekommen, wir nehmen das Thema nicht ernst.
Völlig ernst.
Ja, ich auch.
So, dann haben wir.
Ähm also eine wichtige Aufgabe der antifaschistischen Polizisten besteht darin, rechtsextreme Chatgruppen ihrer Kollegen zu unterbannen und dort mit linken Parolen Karl Marx, und Stadienbildern gezielt dagegen zu halten.
Ja
Im täglichen Dienst sollen immer Antifa und Nazipolizisten paarweise Streifen fahren und sich gegenseitig in Schach halten.
Das ist geil.
Apolle, böser Bulle.
Fragt sich nur, welcher ist jetzt welcher?
Kommt doof an.
Wie das wo ankommt, wenn der dann irgendwie auf dem.
Auf deine Hautfarbe an Tim.
Die internationale Pfeift. Wir werden's sehen. Wir werden's sehen.
Okay, so ähm kommen wir zu den ernsthafteren Themen.
Hackereien.
Hakerei, ja und zwar ähm,
gab es vor einiger Zeit eine Schwachstelle, die haben wir auch behandelt bei. Diese Schwachstelle wurde genannt und eignete sich quasi zu so einer sofortigen Übernahme von äh Sitrix-Umgebung oder Citrix,
Sessions. Und äh Citrix ist äh im Prinzip so ein fern Zugangstool, beziehungsweise eher so eine Lösung für,
nicht nur einen fairen Zugang, sondern direkt für so ein, ja, zentralisiertes Bereitstellen von Services.
Homeoffice heißt das jetzt, Homeoffice.
Ja, also genau, Home Office, Fernzugänge und so, da gibt's eben diese Trittricks.
Also was früher nur Systemadministrator benutzt haben und jetzt ein bisschen alle damit klarkommen.
Genau, irgendwann haben die Systeme gesagt, mach das doch mit meinem Tool. So und ähm in diesem.
Rahmen dieser Schwachstelle, also als sie bekannt wurde, wurde auch sehr dazu geraten, jetzt unglaublich dringend zu patchen und zu gucken, ob bestehende Systeme vielleicht kompromittiert wurden und ähm.
Das haben einige getan, einige nicht getan und die Angreifer haben, so war die Vermutung und die Vermutung scheint sich zu bestätigen.
Eben einfach mal ganz schnell mit dieser Schwachstelle, wo sie wussten, da da pätschen jetzt bald viele. Erstmal so einen Fuß in die Tür geholt,
und dann nachher sich um ihre äh erreichten Angriffsziele gekümmert. Und das scheint jetzt hier dem Uniklinikum Düsseldorf passiert zu sein, äh wo also eine Angreifergruppe das ähm.
Sich quasi in das System reingeheckt hat, das klassische, wie wir's äh auch schon äh geschildert haben.
In unserer Folge, äh in der wir mal diese Angriffe äh in Ruhe auseinandergenommen haben, ähm wo man also dann,
sich Domänenadministrationsrechte holt und dann eben Rechner verschlüsselt. So und das haben die in der im Uniklinikum Düsseldorf gemacht
dreißig Server des Krankenhauses verschlüsselt und damit die Klinik weitgehend außer Betrieb gesetzt. Ähm Operationen,
wurden verschoben, abgesagt, Behandlungen und so weiter, ne, Rettungswagen, konnten die Klinik nicht mehr anfahren, die hatten halt keine IT mehr. Ähm
das Tragische an der Geschichte ist, ähm die hatten wohl eigentlich gedacht, sie wären in der Universität Düsseldorf und haben,
ihre Erpressungsnotiz dann auch an die Universität Düsseldorf geschrieben. Und tatsächlich hat die Uni-Klinik Düsseldorf dann eben geantwortet, ey Leute, ihr seid hier in der falschen Straße,
Ihr habt hier gerade ein Krankenhaus lahmgelegt.
Der geht so nicht. Und dann haben die ähm Angreifer tatsächlich die äh die Entschlüsselungsmöglichkeit kostenlos bereitgestellt und haben gesagt, oh, okay, shit, sorry, war nicht unsere Absicht.
Aber es gab eine äh achtundsiebzigjährige Notfallpatientin,
eingeliefert werden sollte und wegen dieser IT-Schwierigkeiten nicht behandelt werden konnte in der Uniklinik Düsseldorf. Die wurde nach Wuppertal gebracht,
Nachbarstadt und verstarb nach dem Transport,
was jetzt quasi so diskutiert wird als potentiell das erste Opfer eines das erste lebend Opfer äh,
eines Hacking-Angriffs äh zumindest im zivilen Bereich. Ja und das ist natürlich dann schon auch sehr.
Tragisch, dass so etwas äh passiert.
Aus einer halben Stunde von der einen Klinik zur anderen.
Ja
Wenn du eben eine Notfallpatientin bist, die ähm eine besondere Behandlung benötigt, ja, also kann ja hier also wenn es äh mit, wenn es IT benötigt, dann ist es vielleicht ein.
CT oder MRT scannen, um Schädelhirntrauma zu untersuchen oder was auch immer. Ja, aber diese Meldung werden wird zum Krankenhaus sicherlich nicht äh ohne Weiteres äh so aus.
Das kann auch einfach sein, dass die komplette Notaufnahme nicht funktioniert hatten, die nicht in der Lage waren, einfach äh Leute aufzunehmen.
Jetzt wäre ich in der würde ich vermuten, dass ein Mensch, der mit dem Tod ringt nicht unbedingt erst mal im Wartezimmer warten muss und mit der Behandlung gewartet wird, bis die,
Kassenkarte ordnungsgemäß gescannt wurde, ne? Also ich würde eher vermuten, dass da auch noch ein medizinische,
die medizinischen Handlungsmöglichkeiten offenbar und auch eingeschränkt waren. Aber ähm mehr habe ich dazu jetzt auch nicht gefunden und muss man vielleicht auch gar nicht finden.
Zeigt einfach nur, wie.
Ja, wie dramatisch halt dieses äh die Abhängigkeit von IT ist und eben auch die Konsequenzen von solchen Angriffen sein.
Dann sind wir ja hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik nie scheu. Die Erfolge der Strafvermittlungsbehörden,
zu betonen und zu feiern. Wir sind ja ohnehin grundsätzlich voll des Lobes für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und man hört es ja selten über die Scherze machen.
So, tatsächlich ist es so, wie hier, ich mache jetzt wirklich mal andere Leute Scherze, nämlich über diese äh Leute, die den äh Wall Street Market betrieben haben,
Da gab's übrigens äh das war hier, kennst du.
Ja, kenne ich.
Der war ich ja mal, ne?
YouTube-Kanal, der so Dinge erklärt.
Genau. Und mit äh hatte ich damals äh viel gesprochen, weil die auch eine Folge gemacht haben über ähm wie der Wallstreet Market,
auseinandergenommen wurde, also wie diese Leute verhaftet wurden, welche Opsek.
Kannst du nochmal sagen, was der Wallstreet Market war?
Ja, das war ein ähm ja online Drogenmarkt, der ähm.
Galt als einer der größten, aber die gelten ja immer als irgendwie einer der äh einer der größten. Und,
wurde von Deutschen betrieben, die unter anderem auch Server hatten im Cyber Bunker, ja? Also eine,
Eine spannende Geschichte rund herum und wir haben uns damals oder simplizimus hat sich damals vor ein paar Monaten war das äh sehr damit auseinandergesetzt, wie also welche Fehler hatten die gemacht
sie am Ende entdeckt wurden, ja? Ähm und das hatte ich, habe ich dir ein bisschen bei geholfen, das einzuordnen, bin ich auch ganz kurz in dem Video,
drin. So und die hatten eben ihre Server da und ähm.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere, man kann sich das Video nochmal anschauen. Wir verlinken das in den. Ähm am es ging im Prinzip dabei darum.
Die sich irgendwie über VPN der eine hatte sich immer über VPN angemeldet und äh ja hatte offenbar nicht äh den Vortrag von Thorsten und mir schaut äh wie man sich ernsthaft vor Erkennung
äh schützt und seine VPN-Verbindung ist eben bei dem einen ist die VPN-Verbindung abgebrochen und dann hat er von seiner echten IP-Adresse Pakete gesendet.
Und bei dem anderen haben sie einfach den VPN-Anbieter überwacht, um quasi also die haben quasi den Server überwacht, die Verbindung zu dem Server,
und die Verbindung zu dem VPN Anbieter und haben dann einfach immer korreliert,
Anschluss ist zu dem Zeitpunkt mit dem VPN verbunden. Und der war so klug, die VPN-Verbindung immer nur dann herzustellen, wenn er sich mit seinem Wallstreet Marketer administrativ verbinden wollte. Ansonsten waren die auch noch klug genug äh,
mit teuren Autos durchs Dorf zu fahren, ne? Also waren alles ganz große Stadt,
Ähm sind jetzt alle ähm soweit ich weiß vor Gericht oder schon äh verurteilt. Und jetzt geht es eben um das,
arbeiten, der im Wallstreet Market entdeckten
Daten, denn jetzt ist es natürlich so, dieser Wallstreet Market ist ja im Prinzip ein Forum, in dem es eben Händlerinnen gibt und Käuferinnen und die können sich Direktnachrichten schicken, die können da Sachen anbieten. Und was ich ja auch schon öfter betont habe, ist.
Diese ganzen illegalen Marktplätze haben im Prinzip das gleiche Problem wie eBay. Nämlich, dass sie äh,
Am Ende Kontakte zwischen Mensch Menschen herstellen, die einander nicht vertrauen können, die keinen Anlass haben, einander zu vertrauen. Und die Lösung dazu ist natürlich quasi so ein System. Wo,
eben du einen Anreiz hast als Händler.
Dein Händlernamen beizubehalten und von jedem äh deiner Kunden eben eine gute,
Bewertung zu bekommen. Da hatten wir auch schon mal Sendungstitel, Logbuch Netzpolitik, ne? Top silkrodor gerne wieder. Und,
jetzt haben die natürlich diesen Server aus dem Regal gezogen und haben Zugriff auf die Daten mit anderen Worten die wissen jetzt,
wen wer ist es da so für Anbieter gibt, äh wie viel die verkauft haben und was die vielleicht eben intern an Daten äh an Daten angegeben haben. Sorry, ich bin ja gegen eine Dose getreten. So und.
Die Ausbeute ist tatsächlich einhundertneunundsiebzig Anbieter von Drogen und anderen illegalen Gütern,
wurden mit Haftbefehlen äh versehen und diese Haftbefehle wurden verstrickt
äh hat Europol mitgeteilt, allein in Deutschland zweiundvierzig Verdächtige festgenommen, in den USA einhunderteinundzwanzig, der,
Wurde geleitet vom Bundeskriminalamt. Weitere Festnahmen noch in Österreich, Großbritannien, Niederlanden und Schweden.
Und das ist die Operation Dysrup-Tor. Also Tor äh das äh.
Netzwerk, über das die jeden Service angebitten wurden. Neun Monate Ermittlungen im Mai zwanzig neunzehn äh war eben der,
die Zerschlagung des äh Wall Street Market ähm.
Vorweg gegangen, eins Komma eins fünf Millionen Kundenkonten und mehr als fünftausendvierhundert Verkäufer, von denen sie jetzt immerhin eben einhundertneunundsiebzig Anbieter,
gecasht haben. Und ja, kann ich nur sagen.
Die ist das Entscheidende, das hat äh nichts damit zu tun, ob der komische Marktplatz auf dem verabredet eben ähm sich im Darknet befindet oder nicht und ich wurde auch, also es gibt Hörer.
Die sich hier offenbar auch mit solchen Technologien beschäftigen, für den niemanden jemals zu ermutigen, aber die berichten mir von Telegram-Gruppen.
In denen äh der Handel jetzt stattfindet. Ich würde sagen, ich würde grundsätzlich davon abraten.
T-Shirts von Attila Hildmann.
Genau, ich würde aber wenn, dann wenigstens nicht in der Chatgruppe von Attila Hildmann.
Oh Mann.
Nee, halte ich für eine, also halte ich für unkluge Ideen, sowas zu machen.
Für Käuferinnen weniger unklug als für Händlerinnen, als Händlerin wär ich sehr vorsichtig irgendwie mehr oder weniger muss hier ja eine Übergabe in Person stattfinden und das ist immer gefährlich. Wäre ich vorsichtig mit.
Kauft. Erinnert mich übrigens, dieses ganze äh detektivische ähm Spüren von so Hacker äh Verbindung,
Ich hatte grade vor vor ein paar Tagen ist mir irgendwie äh über meine Timeline äh dieser schöne Film, den ich noch gar nicht so richtig zu Ende geschaut hatte,
damals die alte Story von Clifford Store, den deutschen KGB Hackern, um Kalk Horch und so, was dann später zu diesem Buch das Kuckucksei,
weil dieser Clifford-Stoll, der so ein Wissenschaftler war, an dieser Uni, wo die sich irgendwie rein.
Aus seinem System rausgepolt hat, ne, der die irgendwie.
Genau und da gibt's einen schönen Film, den verlinken wir auch, wo äh wo er so seine seine akribische Tätigkeit und seinen seinen ganzen seine ganzen äh Vorgehensweisen, wie er unter den damaligen Bedingungen,
herausgefunden hat, wo die denn herkommen.
Und wie die dann äh ermittelt werden konnten, wie das dann so dargelegt ist und das ist äh doch eine sehr äh schöne Geschichte der Clip Hot Store ist auch ein lustiger Typ.
Muss man sagen. Ist irgendwie auch immer noch äh im Internet äh präsent.
Ja und da kann man mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie das so in in den achtziger Jahren abgelaufen ist. Aber es hat sich irgendwie auch so viel nicht dran geändert, song. Es gibt immer irgendwelche Spuren, die man hinterlässt.
Ja ähm ich äußere mich da wenig zu. Ich habe da ja auch beruflich mit zu tun. Ähm weiß nicht, ob das noch immer so viel Spaß macht, wie bei Clifford Store.
Vielleicht macht's dir Spaß um für Leute, um das jetzt mal so nachzuvollziehen, weißt du? So diese diese detektivische äh Leistung ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz interessante.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, also man kann da äh sehr akribisch vorgehen und deswegen
betonen und loben wir das ja auch bei der Polizei, weil das ist ja die gleiche Polizei, deren Verantwortliche Innenminister und irgendwie Dienststellenleiter und,
und so weiter und LKA-Leiter die ganze Zeit behaupten ähm man wäre jetzt hier ähm.
Man wäre hier irgendwie blind, ne und äh da muss man doch wirklich sagen, äh da haben die doch echt äh würdigen die die Arbeit der Kolleginnen und Kollegen nicht.
Adam, bleiben wir noch ganz kurz bei den Hackern.
Beginnt der Prozess gegen diesen Orbit grade. Das ist der ähm Teenager, der Anfang letzten Jahres ähm,
Aufsehen erregte, weil er die persönlichen Daten von vielen Prominenten und ähm Politikerinnen veröffentlicht hat.
Genau, über Twitter, also auf verschiedenen ähm.
Ja, wie heißen die denn? Plattformen, hier so den Nachfolgern und so war das alles veröffentlicht und hat dann diesen.
Adventskalender da gemacht. Und dann irgendwann hat er am Ende seines Adventskalenders alles geleakt und dann war Großes äh großes,
großes Thema, ja? Und wir haben da damals auch hier ausführlich äh zugesprochen. Und dann war ja die große Frage. Wir haben das, wie gesagt, Anfang letzten Jahres äh auf ausführlich besprochen. Wo hat er die Daten her?
Und.
Info dot com einfach runtergeladen, ja? Dieser Service, von dem wir auch gesprochen haben, der vor ein paar Monaten dann auch
eingestellt wurde. Sieht danach aus, dass der irgendwie nach Jugendstrafrecht eine relativ milde Strafe bekommt,
Das ist äh Aufgabe der Richterin, das zu beurteilen, aber ähm,
Zumindest die eine Hypothese hält sich sehr stark, das äh die ich damals auch von Anfang an vertreten habe, dass das eher eine Frage der Akribie war als eine Frage des,
Bei dem jungen Mann? Also eher eine Frage von Akripie und äh krimineller Energie.
Ähm als oder Geltungsdrang, als jetzt irgendwie, dass der irgendwie besondere Fähigkeiten gehabt hätte.
Wer auch keine besonderen Fähigkeiten hat, ist ja die SCHUFA.
Ja
Die müssen ja trotzdem jeweils neue Geschäftsmodelle entwickeln und die Schufa äh plant jetzt.
Eine neue Form von Datenbank für ihre Kundinnen und Kunden anzubieten. Und zwar.
Stellen sie fest, dass es eine Nachfrage gibt, der Energieversorger, also der Strom- und Gasanbieter nach eventuell einer Datenbank, in der Menschen.
Verzeichnet werden, die regelmäßig den Anbieter wechseln,
Zwar ist es ja so, dass die sehr häufig so Log-Angebote haben. Die setzen ja im Prinzip darauf, dass dass sie dich einmal mit einem mit einem günstigen Angebot ködern,
und dann kriegst du irgendeinen Brief, den du, den du ignorierst, in dem gesagt wird übrigens
Kilowattstundenpreis erhöhen, pipapo, ne? Und dann hast du irgendwie so einen Stromanbieter, bis es vergessen hast, ne. Übrigens ähnlich wie ich, ich glaube, ich habe auch seit,
vielen Jahren einen gleichen Stromanbieter. Und äh wenn ich einen Brief von dem kriege, erinnere ich mich auch immer, wer das ist?
Selbstverständlich. Selbstverständlich solar und Wind. Kommt natürlich trotzdem hier aus dem Atomkraftwerk nebenan,
aber ähm äh mit dem Geld investieren die ja dann rein. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Es wäre ja total ärgerlich, wenn es Menschen gäbe, die aus reiner,
Boshaftigkeit, das sind ja schlechte Menschen,
Die aus reiner Boshaftigkeit einfach mal jedes Jahr gucken, was der günstigste Angebot, das nehme ich. Ja, solche Menschen wollen wir nicht. Solche Menschen wollen wir nicht in unserer Gesellschaft, da müssen wir eine Datenbank haben,
ja? Und die möchte die Schufa jetzt bauen, ja? Ähm um.
Die um den Unternehmen es zu ermöglichen, systematisch Kunden abzulehnen, die häufig wechseln und deshalb für die Firmen wirtschaftlich unattraktiv sind,
die sich nach weil die günstigen Preise suchen und sich nicht dauerhaft an sie binden. Ähm das finde ich schon bärenstark, diese Bestrebung, ne?
Ja, ich meine, so war es freie Marktwirtschaft nicht gemeint.
Echt so eine. Wie, du kommst nur, weil wir die nur du kommst nur zu uns, wenn wir mal die Günstigsten sind.
Seit seit wann regelt das der Markt? Also wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Alter! Also das wird jetzt noch irgendwie in in den Datenschutzkonferenzen und so diskutiert, der ähm
die die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten halten sich da jetzt erstmal ein bisschen zurück, aber ähm ich denke,
hier wird man sich schon die Frage gefallen lassen, ob das vom Datenschutzrecht überhaupt gedeckelt ist, ja? Also, dass dass du jetzt unterschreibst, so
Ja, ja, nehme ich mal in die nehme ich meine Datenbank auf, wann ich das letzte Mal meinen Stromanbieter gekündigt habe?
Nicht da, damit ich wenn wenn ihr nicht dann demnächst die Preise erhöht und jemand anderes günstiger ist, ich nicht nachher hier die Prinzipien des Marktes gegen euch anwende und einfach mir mein günstigeres Angebot suche.
Das finde ich schon also wenn die das dürfen, ne.
Gut, würde mich mal interessieren, wie da die Zahlen sind, ne. Also wie viele machen das? Es gibt ja jetzt mittlerweile diese sogenannten Vergleichsplattformen, die einem so einen Wechsel ja dann auch relativ leicht machen.
Klar, weil die auch die Provisionen abstreichen.
Genau und ähm da sind dann vielleicht auch diese Provisionen so ein bisschen das Problem. Also
Schwierig, ne? Also letzten Endes ist ist das Problem ja die Art und Weise, wie die Unternehmen ihre Kunden auch versuchen zu kriegen über solche Angebote und über solche Plattformen und gut, bei Strom
kann ich das verstehen, auch bei im Telekommunikationsmarkt ist das ja auch mal wieder ein Thema oder Gas generell, also Energienetz, alles, was so,
Auf den ersten Blick,
die Dienstleistung ja immer gleich ist. Du kannst dich ja als Stromanbieter du lieferst ja kein geileren Strom oder Besseres.
Sie ja auch mal machen. Bei uns gibt's zweihundertsechzig Volt.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als geileren Strom bezeichnen.
Mit Wiepower.
Ja, ne, aber das ist natürlich ein äh ist natürlich schon ein Problem, weil klar, wir machen das irgendwie, wir gehen da so nach einem Idealistischen äh Vorgang und schauen vielleicht jetzt nicht aufs letzte Cent.
So, ja, ist uns dann irgendwie egal, ob der Strom irgendwie einunddreißig oder zweiunddreißig Cent äh pro Kilowattstunde kostet? Weiß ich gar nicht, wie die aktuell.
So teuer ist der bei dir? Musst du mal öfter wechseln.
Hast du so einen Tipp, wo's gerade billiger ist?
Äh ich gucke mal hier, hier gibt's einen Empfehlungs, also ich weiß nicht, wie oft hast du denn schon gewechselt? Vielleicht nehmen die nicht noch.
Ich bin eigentlich ein sehr treuer Kunde. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie in der Schufa landen werde, aber wer weiß das schon so ganz genau?
Vor allem bist du ja bei deinem sehr treuer Kunde entgegen aller Geißelung.
Ja, die schaffen's äh irgendwie am äh am Ende immer wieder irgendwie so ein Kniff freizuschalten, wo ich sage, so ah okay, war jetzt ganz praktisch.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine, also die die Schufa argumentiert, ihre Daseinsberechtigung daher, dass sie den Leuten helfen, sich zu,
da die die Leute dafür schützen, sich zu überschulden,
Ja, aber die Schufa hat mir nicht dabei zu helfen, mich zu übersparen. Beim Strom.
Das ist einfach nicht in Ordnung. Eine derartige Partei zu führen und ich denke, damit das wird ein gefundenes Fressen für ähm.
Für eine Klage, oder?
Denke ich auch, also das geht nicht. Das geht nicht.
Ich wechsel jetzt erst ich wechsel jetzt den Stromanbieter.
Ich gucke gerade, was ich.
Wobei lieber nicht während der Sendung, wer weiß, nicht, dass ihr das soll ja so schnell gehen heutzutage, nicht, dass ihr zwischendurch kurz der Strom ausfällt, ne. Also stell dir mal vor, Strom an, Vita Wechsel, wer so scheiße wie Internetanbieter wechselt. Ja, ja, wir kommen.
Heute Nachmittag kommen wir.
Dreizehn Uhr kommen wir dann. Also wir waren um siebzehn Uhr da war ja bei ihnen brannte kein Licht da sind wir wieder gegangen.
Dreiundzwanzig Komma drei zwo Cent bis fünfundzwanzig bis fünfundzwanzig Cent. Billiger als ich dachte.
Kann man direkt mehr, hier steht das gar nicht. Ähm beim bei meinem Anbieter.
Also da kommt ja natürlich immer noch der Grundpreis dazu, von daher ist das dann auch äh relativ. Müsste ich mal so einen effektiven Kilowattstunden ähm Betrag ausrechnen.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht, was aber ich muss meine Postleitzahl eingeben, nee, nee. Also ähm die letzte Meldung habe ich gar nicht mehr richtig vorbereitet
diese TikTok Weatch Sache hat sich irgendwie weiter verschärft, dann aber doch nicht mehr. Dann hat Trump gesagt, jetzt hier Sonntag, machen wir das alles aus, dann hat irgendeine Richterin gesagt, selbst wo verrückt, lass das sein und es sieht jetzt im Moment danach aus, dass,
ORR, dass irgendwie diesen Handel vollziehen möchte, mit TikTok eine.
US-amerikanisch gehandelte Entität zu schaffen und gleichzeitig zieht,
China, aber jetzt irgendwie Schutzmöglichkeiten ein, um
da im in dieser Übernahme sich vor einem Abfluss des Intellecturalty, also der Algorithmen zu schützen, das ist also insgesamt ist das alles ich kann es nur als eine absolute Shit-Show bezeichnen, was da passiert.
Und deswegen möchte ich empfehlen, hat uns auch äh wo wir auch durch einen Hörer darauf hingewiesen, ich habe die Mail leider jetzt nicht,
Mehr vorliegen, das ist jetzt auf Netflix. Eine schöne Doku mit dem Namen The Social Dilemma gibt. Wahrscheinlich heißt sie auf Deutsch anders,
ähm und da geht es um.
Den gesellschaftlichen, den negativen, gesellschaftlichen Einfluss von sozialen Netzwerken.
Im weitesten Sinne, aber auch insbesondere der Techniken, die sie verwenden, um.
Unsere Aufmerksamkeit
zu erlangen. Ähm bekannte Personen, die in diesem Film auftreten, sind einmal Christopher, das ist der äh Autor des Buches mein Fakt, der im Prinzip diesen ganzen Cambridge Analytica
Skandal damals ins Rollen brachte mit seiner äh als mit seinen Aussagen dazu.
Jerome ja mit ja etwas zugespitzten Aussagen schon länger von sich,
Reden macht in dieser Doku mir aber jetzt nicht besonders negativ aufgefallen ist und,
der bei Google früher war und,
inzwischen seine eigene Organisation hat jetzt fällt mir der Name nicht mehr genau ein, aber die sich im Prinzip
Ich glaube oder so was heißen die. Mir fällt es jetzt leider gerade nicht mehr ein, muss man ganz kurz in meinen Mails schauen, weil wir haben äh wir waren damals schon ein bisschen mit ihm in Kontakt und hatten auch gehofft, ihn beim Camp zu haben
heißen die. Ähm hatten ähm Hoffnung
den auch beim äh Camp zu haben mit einem Vortrag, das hat dann aber sehr kurzfristig dann leider doch nicht hingehauen. Und der setzt sich.
Ähm jetzt gar nicht unbedingt damit auseinander,
was jetzt hier die Manipulationsmacht der sozialen Medien ist, sondern welche psychologischen Mechanismen die benutzen, um dich im Prinzip süchtig nach ihrem Service zu machen,
Also, die Notifications, die du so kriegst und ähm.
Die Belohnungen oder dass dass das Ding dich auffordert, ne, sowieso hat,
hallo gesagt, reagiere jetzt darauf oder dass zum Beispiel die Notification eben äh solange sie nur auf deinem Bildschirm ist,
nicht das Foto dabei ist, damit du halt noch die App öffnest, wieder damit interagierst und äh so weiter. Die Doku ist ähm,
Ja, ich also ja, ist jetzt blöd zu sagen, dass für mich da jetzt nix großartig neu drin war, ähm weil ich mich aber mit diesem Thema äh seit vielen Jahren auseinandersetze, auf jeden Fall ist es in dieser Doku nochmal sehr schön,
ähm gearbeitet und regt zur Reflexion darüber an und ich habe dann auch nochmal ähm.
Auch wenn am Ende die Empfehlungen der äh in diesem,
in dieser Doku zur Sprache kommenden Expertinnen relativ äh mager sind äh habe ich dann trotzdem auch mal ein bisschen meine Notifications hier,
in meinem mobilen Betriebssystem doch mal neu angepasst darauf, was ich denn wirklich brauche und was. Also kann man auf jeden Fall schauen und kann man auch empfehlen.
Also du, du fährst ein Engagement sozusagen runter mit den Plattformen.
Nicht, dass ich damit in irgendeiner Schufa-Datenbank lande, als schlechter Klicker.
Ich wollte schon sagen, also das geht auf deinen Social Score, ne?
Ja, aber ich habe, aber das habe ich also das habe ich ohnehin schon immer bin da darum immer bemüht,
wer mir E-Mails schreibt, weiß, dass da längere Zeit auf Antwort gewartet wird, wer versucht mich irgendwie über Twitter zu erreichen oder so,
weiß, dass ich da in der Regel, also das ist alles nicht mit Notifikationen versehen.
Du ziehst dich also raus aus dem Netz.
Nein, ich bin ja ich bin ja hier immer noch drin, es zieht mich ja zu den Menschen, aber es es ist auf jeden Fall nicht nicht so schlecht, sich dieser Phänomene auf jeden Fall äh bewusst zu werden.
Falls sie sich doch irgendwann wieder zum Internet ziehen sollte, die Nos, ja, dann braucht man ja auch einen Anschluss. Ist ja schon klar, ne?
Anschluss ist ja in Deutschland ein bisschen schwierig. Also man hat ja gedacht so, okay, jetzt hat sich der Osten im Westen,
angeschlossen, das reicht jetzt auch erstmal mit Anschluss. Mehr Anschluss braucht's nicht und äh erst heute wird uns ja auch so klar.
Was uns eigentlich alles so verloren gegangen ist. Damals, unter anderem,
auch viele interessante Glasfaserprojekte, ne? Also ist wirklich so absurd. Ja, Opal, also das sogenannte Opal, Ghetto.
Optische Anschlussleitung.
Hatte hatte einen schlechten Ruf, aber nur, weil's nicht überall war. Und weiß da nicht weitergebaut wurde, weil alle auf dieses äh billige DSL aus den USA gesetzt haben, anstatt äh zu sagen, so nö, wir ziehen das jetzt mal durch,
im Prinzip war ja die deutsche Bundespost Ende der achtziger Jahre,
drauf und dran, Deutschland mit einer Glasfaserinfrastruktur zu versorgen und hätten sie das mal weitergemacht,
Und äh ja, das Opal-Ghetto ist dann halt so ein bisschen in den schlechten Ruf gekommen, aber das lag ja nicht an der optischen Anschlussleitung, sondern das liegt nur daran, dass sich
dass dich dann keiner mehr an die optische Anschlussleitung anschließen wollte. Und jetzt haben wir dann eben die letzten Jahrzehnte
mit diesen ganzen Kupferanschluss äh weiter verbracht, aus dem dann halt noch mal irgendwie
Frequenz nach der anderen rausgequetscht wurde und hier nochmal ein Megabit und da nochmal und was auch immer gerade da so aus aus diesem dünnen Draht noch grade so rausgedrückt werden konnte
war dann immer so der aktuelle,
Bandbreiten Hype. Ja, jetzt noch Megabit mehr und noch ein Megabit mehr und wir hatten das Thema jetzt hier auch schon irgendwie so einige Male.
Und irgendwie hat das ja auch so als sedierender Wirkstoff,
funktioniert, ne? Also Leute haben ja gesagt, so ja ich brauche ja auch nicht mehr und was soll ich denn und jetzt habe ich schon hundert Megabit und wann wann
nutze ich denn das schon mal und so? Und äh ja gut, das mag ja äh durchaus sein, dass dass Leute über Anschlüsse verfügen, die die sie nicht ausnutzen,
ist ja auch kein Grund,
anderen Leuten, die sie sehr wohl ausnutzen, äh die dann trotzdem zur Verfügung zu stellen, weil die da was mit anfangen können, ne. Man, dein Auto fährt wahrscheinlich auch schneller, als du irgendwie normalerweise fährst, aber gibt halt manchmal.
Ich habe gar kein Auto.
Du hast kein Auto. Ich habe gar kein Internetanschluss. Na ja,
Auf jeden Fall scheint sich das jetzt aber so langsam mal rumgesprochen zu haben, dass das eine scheiß Idee war. Und tatsächlich hat der Bundestag,
ein neues Gesetz äh beschlossen ja, was äh versucht gleich mit mehreren Problemen ähm so ein bisschen äh ein Ende zu finden, nämlich dieses Problem, dass du als,
Selbst wenn du Eigentümer in einem Haus bist, also sagen wir mal, dir gehört eine Wohnung innerhalb eines Häuser äh Komplexes.
Dass äh du jederzeit von dieser Eigentümer,
Versammlung überstimmt werden konntest, wenn du eigentlich sinnvolle Sachen gefordert hast. Das betrifft zum Beispiel eben das Fettliegen von Glasfaser, aber auch so andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Barrierefreiheit,
oder eben jetzt auch ganz aktuell der äh Anschluss eines Ladeports in der Garage. Ne, wenn du jetzt in so einem.
Eigentums äh Cluster Wohns, wo alle so ihre Wohnung haben, dann hast du da so Garagen und dann äh ja ich will mir aber jetzt hier Elektroauto kaufen und wie wär's denn mal mit einer Steckdose? Sagen die anderen, ja ist viel zu teuer.
Jetzt gibt's auf jeden Fall dieses neue Gesetz und dieses Gesetz,
verhindert eben für diese Fälle, dass du überstimmt werden kannst, mit anderen Worten, wenn ein Eigentümer der Meinung ist, das hat jetzt mal zu sein, dann können die anderen äh dem nichts mehr entgegensetzen.
Das ist zumindest die ähm der Objektive, das Ziel des Gesetzesentwurfs zur Förderung der Elektromobilität und zur Modernisierung des Wohneigentums,
Gesetzes,
und äh ja, es soll also hier jedem Wohnungseigentümer ermöglicht werden, bauliche Veränderungen durchzusetzen, die dem Gebrauch durch Menschen mit Behinderung, dem Laden elektrisch betriebener Fahrzeuge, dem Einbruchschutz
und dem Glasfaseranschluss dienen. Da sind wir also jetzt, ne? Glasfaseranschluss hat jetzt die selbe Bedeutung, wie Auto betanken oder,
Behinderungsprobleme aufzulösen.
Klingt erstmal ganz gut. Ist allerdings, ich habe mal kurz in diesen Text reingeschaut, etwas schwammig formuliert, zum Beispiel gibt's da so eine Formulierung, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das die äh letztlich definierende ist, aber ja, es ist zum Beispiel bauliche Veränderungen, die in dem Anschluss an ein solches Netz, wenn sie dem Wohnungseigentümer in seinem Sondereigentum
Nutzung eines Telekommunikationsnetzes eröffnen, das entweder komplett aus Glasfaserkomponenten.
Zumindest bis zum Verteilerpunkt am Orte der Nutzung besteht, dann würde ich sagen, ja okay,
Nutzung, zumindest, also nehme ich, weil der Ort der Nutzung ist ja bei mir zu Hause, also da will ich dann das Glasfaser auch haben, ne?
Jetzt kommt aber wieder so ein oder,
oder das zu üblichen Spitzenlastzeiten eine ähnliche Netzleistung in Bezug auf die verfügbare Download
und Ablenkbandbreite, Ausfallsicherheit, Fehler bezogene Parameter, Latenz und Latenzschwankungen bieten kann.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Den Satz, der ist das würde ich in den Antrag an die Eigentümerversammlung einfach schreiben, dass das erfüllt ist, das soll die.
Also, was im Prinzip, was sie hier sagen, ist eigentlich muss es Glasfaser sein, sollte es aber irgendwie was geben, was dieselben Anforderungen.
Katastrophenwarn-App machen, die nicht ganz so gut funktioniert, aber ohne Sirene.
Ja gut, ich meine, das will ich erstmal sehen äh über welchen anderen Weg du quasi,
dieselbe Latenz und Latenzschwankung hinbekommst. Wo, was ich hier zum Beispiel mal geltend machen würde, ist
Sagen wir mal, du legst Glasfaser nicht in die Wohnung, sondern du legst es in so einen Verteilerpunkt im Haus und dann ist da auch ein ordentlicher dran, der da irgendwie mit äh,
Mit zehn Gigabit, das durchs Haus brät, da würde ich dann mitgehen, ja, dann ist das sozusagen das die Downlink und Ablenkbandbreite auch gesichert und die,
und die Latenzschwankungen, also da äh ist dann auch nicht mehr so viel rauszuholen. Aber was äh hier im wesentlichen doch fallen sollte, durch diese Formulierung ist halt der Anschluss über Kupfer. Denn und das machen sich ja auch viele Leute nicht klar, die sagen,
Wieso hier, ich habe doch mein Kabelanschluss bei Kabel Deutschland und die versprechen mir hier irgendwie megabit und guck mal, ich habe ja hier auch so und so viel Download.
Ja, mag sein, kann alles äh hinhauen. Nur, wenn man sich das eben mal wirklich auf Netzebene anschaut, also wenn man mal genau hinschauen würde, wie viele Fehler und man hat.
Ja, also wie lange manchmal ein Paket dann doch braucht, bis es wirklich kommt. Am Ende magst du zwar ordentliche Downloadzeiten haben und es mag für dich auch,
vielleicht das primäre, der primäre Nutzen einer schnellen Internetverbindung sein, dass du einen schnellen Download hast, aber spätestens zu Corona haben wir ja auch gelernt.
Na ja so Latenz ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz unwichtig. Videokonferenzen, Audiokonferenzen et cetera leben auch davon, dass man sich irgendwie ähm,
Ja äh so schnell unterbrechen kann, dass es gar nicht erst so richtig zu einer Unterbrechung führt, sondern man sich darüber abstimmt, aber wenn irgendwie alles mit einer Sekunde Verzögerung passiert, dann wird's halt richtig
eklig. Und das sind halt alles so Dinge. Ähm es wird halt nie besser als äh das Medium, auf dem du aufsetzt und wenn schon dein Kupferkabel, das gilt ja letztlich auch für normalen Kabelanschluss. Oft
wenn das eben schon solche Fehler erzeugt und so damit eben auch solche Latenzen erzeugt, dann dann kann's dadrüber nicht besser werden. Na ja
Also äh angeblich ist der Glasfaserinteressenverband VATM noch nicht so ganz so glücklich, ob dieser äh schwammigen Formulierung oder auch vielleicht noch irgendeine anderen Formulierung, die ich nicht gefunden habe, aber immerhin
gibt's jetzt sowas? Wird ja langsam was. Also ich glaub jetzt haben Sie das langsam verstanden. Es war ja auch einfach,
zu peinlich. Wobei, was sie nicht verstanden haben, das muss man an dieser Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal genau sagen. Wir haben in Deutschland immer noch nicht,
Und es zeichnet sich meiner Meinung auch nicht ab, dass wir das bekommen werden. Noch nicht den richtigen Ansatz wie Telekommunikationsnetze aufgebaut werden sollen.
Dieses ganze Ding mit Glasfaser ist jetzt eigentlich nur die nächste Augenwischerei auf die wir jetzt kommen, weil jetzt heißt es ja, na ja, wenn die Telekom dir einen Glasfaseranschluss zu Hause hinlegt, dann ist doch alles super, was willst du denn eigentlich?
Ja gut, wenn die Telekom mir da einen ordentlichen Tarif macht und da irgendwie schnelle Daten rausfallen. Meinetwegen,
aber ich will ja auch meinen Anbieter mal wechseln können. Alle zwanzig Minuten, damit ich einen schönen Eintrag bei der Schufa kriege.
Ja ähm und dafür haben wir einfach nicht das richtige System, denn derzeit wird ja im Prinzip,
von privaten Firmen auf Antrag irgendwo im Land Infrastruktur verbuddelt,
je nachdem wie die sich dann mit den Hauseigentümern einigen können, landet halt der eine Anbieter oder der andere Anbieter da, das haben wir bei Kabelfernsehen schon gesehen und das ist jetzt im Prinzip bei diesen ganzen Glasfaseranschlüssen genau dasselbe Ding,
weil es wirft immer wieder Kosten auf
Anschluss am Haus, ist sozusagen auch noch nicht das Ende vom Lied, du willst es ja eigentlich haben, also in die Wohnung haben. Das bedeutet, dass Glasfaserleitung auch innerhalb des Hauses verlegt werden müssen, das ist aber jetzt nicht so eine Technologie, wie
Strom oder Wasser, wo du einfach irgendeinen Installateur nehmen kannst und dann dann ist es richtig, sondern da kann eben auch noch sehr viel falsch gemacht werden, deswegen haben wir da nicht den Standard, dann kommen halt die Firmen und sagen, na ja, nee, dann wollen wir das aber auch alles selber machen, damit es auch funktioniert, damit wir da keinen Ärger haben
so ein bisschen verstehen kann, aber irgendwo ist die Sache nicht rund, weil wir es nicht,
Weil wir nicht mit Helmut Kohl gegangen sind. Dinos, ist das überhaupt klar, dass Helmut Kohl eigentlich der größte visionäre Telekommunikation ist? Und er wusste es selber nicht.
Gartenautobahn oder was?
Ja, er sprach ja mal von der Datenautobahn und ganz Deutschland hat sich irgendwie den Bauch gehalten. Und ich muss sagen, ich.
Ungefähr die Abdeckung haben wir inzwischen aber auch erreicht.
Abdeckung, du meinst ähm welche.
Autobahnnetz, ja.
Und vor allem, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie ist denn die Autoautobahn organisiert? Die Autobahn ist vom Staat bezahlt, vom Staat betrieben,
jeder hat da freien Zugang drauf. Du kannst an jeder Ausfahrt und Abfahrt runterfahren. Okay, du hast jetzt Maut und so, okay, gut, anderer äh Aspekt, aber,
Es ist eine Infrastruktur, die allen zur Verfügung steht und auf der sich dann eben Business und privates Leben einfach abspielen kann und wo jeder im Prinzip Dienstleistungen drauf anbieten kann,
und übertragen auf eine Telekommunikation, müssten wir halt eigentlich ein System haben, wo Glasfasern, die in Häusern gehen,
jedem Zugang bieten müssen. Es müssen eigentlich reine ähm.
Wie man so schön sagt, Dark Fibers sein, also unbeleuchtet, sprich das Kabel liegt da, also das die die die Faser liegt da, aber,
mit wem sie sich verbindet im ersten Schritt, bleibt offen. Ja und,
kennt die Beispiele aus Schweden und anderen nordischen Ländern, Pop, vielen anderen Ländern, die nicht Deutschland sind, dann gehst du halt in so eine Wohnung rein.
Oder hast diesen Anschluss und steckst dich da irgendwie mit Isonet rein, also dein Glasfaser kommt halt irgendwie an und dein Übergabepunkt ist so ein Iserlett und dann steckst du dich da rein oder hast vielleicht gleich so ein WLAN, wie auch immer. Und die erste Seite, die du aufrufst, ist halt quasi so die Seite von deinem,
Gerät und das sagt dann hallo, ich bin's, dein dein Anschluss an das Internet,
Provider hätten's denn gern? Und dann hast du da eine Liste mit Telekom, hättest du gerne O2, hättest du gerne hier deinen lokalen Provider. Preise hier und dann sagst du ja, ich nehme gern den und dann hast du Internet.
So einfach kann es sein und so einfach müsste es meiner Meinung nach auch sein und das ist irgendwie so eine Zukunft, von der ich noch nicht weiß, ob wir auf die zurollen, aber eigentlich müsste die Gesetzesinitiative in Deutschland,
auf sowas hinauslaufen, dass wir da einfach gute Pro Weile haben können, dass man die jederzeit wechseln kann
keine ordentliche Infrastruktur hinkriegen, wenn die mit ihrem IPV sechs Scheiße machen, wenn ihr den Esser scheiße läuft, wenn ihr irgendwelchen blöden Sperren äh falsch umsetzen, wenn die einfach Kacke sind oder wenn die einfach keinen ordentlichen Peerings haben zu anderen Providern, dann,
wechselst du einfach deinen Provider und zwar nicht nach vierundzwanzigsten Monaten, wenn dein Vertrag ausläuft, sondern halt sage ich Montag.
So wollen wir das, so wollen wir das, Tim.
So wollen wir das haben. Wünsche dir was. Mit laut Buchnetzpolitik.
Genau, wir kämpfen für euer Fiber to the home. Bettkante.
Ja. Ich finde das aber sehr schön, also dass dass Helmut Kohl mit der Datenautobahn das bessere Internet äh visioniert hatte ähm.
Keiner zugehört.
Alle haben alle haben sie gelacht. Genauso wie wenn du dir schnelles Netz wünschst.
Ja. Schlimm. Ich und Helmut. Wir sind total.
Lasst den alten Mann reden. Timmut Helmut, Helmut Helmut, hätten das damals geklärt für uns.
Wir sind wieder einfach verkannt. Ja, die Geschichte ist an uns vorbeigegangen, ist ein Trauer.
Da hättest du noch einige Mauern niedergerissen im im Internet.
Ich sage dir, was ich noch alles vereinigt hätte.
Okay, ich glaube, damit äh sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Wir können also jetzt, ich würde sagen, ich nehme jetzt die Hiltie und bohre hier unten schon mal einen Stromanschluss für mein Elektroauto. Kann mir ja keiner mehr verbieten.
Ja, wechsel ich den Stromanbieter und wenn ich schon dabei bin, kann ich eigentlich direkt weiter bohren für die Faser.
So sieht's aus.
So, also ich meine, anders wird das hier nix mehr. Wir müssen tatsächlich auch erkennen, um jetzt mal die historischen historischen gleich zu bleiben, dass wir hier tatsächlich die digitalen Trümmerfrauen der Republik sind und hier was aufbauen müssen, so.
Aber nicht zu groß das Loch machen, weil es muss ja auch dem Einbruchschutz gerecht werden.
Ich mache das direkt äh ich mache da direkt ein barrierefreies Loch.
Alright.
Okay. Damit sind wir äh am Ende der Sendung.
Willst du noch danke sagen.
Ich würde gerne danken, ja und zwar habe ich äh eine äh Reihe an Leuten, denen mein besonderer Dank gilt. Das ist insbesondere Rüdiger und Nils.
Und äh Benjamin und Rumo und natürlich Jonas, Lukas, Tobias,
und Christian, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Und vielen Dank an alle regelmäßigen Unterstützer von Logbuch und der Metaebene im Allgemeinen und macht das auch bitte äh weiterhin.
Ähm hilft auf jeden Fall.
Damit entlassen wir euch in diese äh Woche. Mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir unsere zeitlichen Ausrutscher auch wieder aufgeholt.
Bis dahin. Tschau, tschau.
Bis bald.